programming throwdown episode 149 workflow engines with sanjay sadanti take it away patrick we're here with another great and exciting episode, a topic that I think we've talked around and most people probably have the problem of needing, but we already said it in intro, so it's not a spoiler. Workflow engines. We all kind of get to this thing. It's a design pattern, I guess, is almost a way of thinking about it. I think a lot of people, when you first discover design patterns, you read the first few and you're like, these are kind of obvious. Why is everyone making such a big deal about software design patterns? Then you sort of start thinking more clearly about them and having the language to describe them and
programming throwdown episode 149 workflow engines with sanjay sadanti take it away patrick we're here with another great and exciting episode, a topic that I think we've talked around and most people probably have the problem of needing, but we already said it in intro, so it's not a spoiler. Workflow engines. We all kind of get to this thing. It's a design pattern, I guess, is almost a way of thinking about it. I think a lot of people, when you first discover design patterns, you read the first few and you're like, these are kind of obvious. Why is everyone making such a big deal about software design patterns? Then you sort of start thinking more clearly about them and having the language to describe them and|||programming throwdown 第 149 期 工作流引擎，嘉宾 Sanjay Sadante。交给你了，Patrick。我们迎来了又一个精彩刺激的节目，这个话题我觉得我们之前或多或少讨论过，而且大多数人可能都有这方面的需求，不过我们在开场白里已经提过了，所以不算剧透。工作流引擎。我们大家都多多少少会接触到这个东西。这是一种设计模式，我猜，几乎可以说是一种思考方式。我觉得很多人在刚接触设计模式时，读了前几个就会觉得：这些不是很明显吗？为什么大家要把软件设计模式吹捧得这么重要？然后你才会开始更清晰地思考它们，并掌握描述它们的语言，以及在|||be succinct, but also precise when you communicate with other software engineers. If you don't know what I'm talking about design patterns, I think we have an episode on them. If not, definitely Google them up and take a look at them. But I think there are other, not captured by necessarily design patterns themselves, but other concepts,|||与其他软件工程师沟通时做到简洁而精确。如果你不知道我在说什么设计模式，我想我们有一期专门讲这个。如果没有，一定要去谷歌搜索一下并了解看看。但我认为还有其他一些概念，未必被设计模式本身所涵盖，但它们是其他一些概念，|||which once you start doing practical, real world software engineering, you start to run into recurring issues. We've talked about some of them that get addressed for things like continuous integration, continuous deployment. The reason why we talk about those are because it's something that comes up again and again.|||一旦你开始从事切实的、现实世界的软件工程，就会开始遇到一些重复出现的问题。我们讨论过其中一些可以通过持续集成、持续 deployment 来解决的问题。我们讨论这些的原因是，它们是不断反复出现的事情。|||When people don't do those things, they run into this set of problems. And it's not the only solution, but it's a recurring and good solution. And so today we're going to talk about some things in that same vein. And here with us today, we have Sanjay Sadante, Director of Engineering at Acasa. Welcome to the show, Sanjay. Thank you. Thanks for having me. Awesome. Well, we always love to start by learning a bit about how people got to where they are. I think life story is just kind of that interesting thing. Maybe it's because I've grown a little more|||当人们不这样做时，就会遇到这一系列问题。而且这并非唯一的解决方案，但它是一个反复出现且不错的方案。所以今天我们要探讨一些与此同脉相承的话题。今天来到我们节目的嘉宾是 Acasa 的工程总监 Sanjay Sadante。欢迎来到节目，Sanjay。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。太好了。嗯，我们总是喜欢从了解大家是如何走到今天这一步开始。我觉得人生故事就是那么有趣。也许是因为我变得更|||mature, a little older. I like hearing how people also have their own journey and also to just sort of learn the diverse ways people end up in jobs is always just fascinating to me because when people always give career advice, there's always like this one way you do things and it's the way they did things. And so I like hearing that breadth. And so do you have, some people do, some people don't. Do you remember kind of like the first time you either like did programming or your first piece of tech or what got you really excited about this field? Yeah, absolutely. I think the first time I programmed a computer was in eighth grade, and I built a simple website just using HTML and CSS. I didn't even use JavaScript at the time,|||成熟了一点，年纪大了一些。我喜欢听听别人也有他们自己的心路历程，而且了解人们最终从事各种工作的不同途径总是让我觉得非常着迷，因为当人们总是给出职业建议时，总是有一种“你必须这样做事，而这就是他们以前的做法”。所以我喜欢听听这种广泛的经历。那么你——有些人有，有些人没有——你还记得第一次编程，或者接触第一件科技产品，或者是什么让你对这个领域真正感到兴奋的时刻吗？是的，绝对的。我想我第一次给计算机编程是在八年级，我只用了 HTML 和 CSS 构建了一个简单的网站。当时我甚至没有使用 JavaScript，|||and I really liked it. And so all through high school, I ended up building a lot of websites and taking AP computer science. So learned a bit of Java. And I came into college with, I'd say, a fair amount of programming experience and pretty sure that I wanted to major in computer science. Awesome. I also took AP computer science and also did Java. But I'm not curious if they still, do you know you know they still teach it in Java? I'm curious if they've gone to something else. You know, I went back to visit the AP Computer Science class at my first, I guess, academic exposures, but also had been programming a bit before. And so yeah, it's interesting, the web design and sort of so HTML, CSS, being able to, you wanted to do computer science, it sounds like. And then when you went to college, you continued to pursue it? Or did you try something else at first? I had a lot of interests going into college. So I was always taking computer science courses, but also a lot of math classes and also a lot of biology. And I wasn't totally sure how I wanted to mix all of these interests. I had, you know, one idea that I might go to medical school and, you know, be a computational person in that space.|||我真的很喜欢它。所以在整个高中期间，我最终构建了许多网站，并修读了 AP 计算机科学。因此学了一点 Java。我带着可以说相当丰富的编程经验进入大学，并且非常确定自己想主修计算机科学。太棒了。我也修过 AP 计算机科学，也学过 Java。不过我很好奇他们现在是否还在——你知道他们现在还在用 Java 教吗？我很想知道他们是否已经换成别的了。你知道的，我回去拜访了 AP 计算机科学课堂，那是我最初的学术接触，不过我之前也已经做过一些编程了。所以，是的，这很有趣，网页设计以及诸如 HTML、CSS 之类的，能够让你——听起来你想从事计算机科学。然后当你上大学时，你继续深造了吗？还是你一开始尝试了别的？我上大学时有很多兴趣。所以我一直在上计算机科学课程，但也有很多数学课以及很多生物学课。我当时并不是很确定该如何将这些兴趣融合在一起。我有一个想法，就是我可能会去医学院，成为该领域的计算生物学人员，|||And another idea that I might be a software engineer. So it took me a couple years in college to sort of figure out what I was interested in. And I would say, once I heard about bioinformatics for the first time, that's when I realized what I really wanted to do. Both my parents are scientists. And so growing up, I was always really interested in science. And we would talk about biology and chemistry at the dinner table. But I didn't ever realize that there were opportunities for computational folks to work on analyzing big data sets in that space. But once I found that in college, that's what I ended up focusing on for the rest of undergrad and for grad school.|||另一个想法是我可能会成为一名软件工程师。所以在大学的前几年里，我花了一些时间才弄清楚自己真正感兴趣的是什么。我想说的是，当我第一次听到“生物信息学”这个词时，我才意识到这正是我真正想做的事。我的父母都是科学家。所以在成长过程中，我对科学一直非常感兴趣。我们经常在餐桌上讨论生物学和化学。但我从未意识到，计算领域的人才居然有机会在该领域从事大数据集的分析工作。但一旦我在大学里发现了这一点，这就成了我在整个本科剩余时间和研究生阶段专注的方向。|||Oh, nice. So I know the term bioinformatics, and I guess using the prefix and suffix and your context, I could guess. And part of me thinks like things like gene folding, I guess, has been like popular recently in the zeitgeist of, you know, some of the machine learning techniques as applied to those. Is that like the bulk of it is stuff related to that? Or is it I assume it's much broader than that, bioinformatics. Can you maybe tell us a little bit about what did that field? Yeah, absolutely. I think if I had to think of a generic definition, it would be using computational techniques to analyze large data sets in biology. And I can give some examples. So, you know, protein folding is|||哦，不错。我听说过生物信息学（bioinformatics）这个词，我想通过前缀、后缀以及你的语境，我可以猜出来。我有一部分想法是，比如基因折叠之类的，我猜最近在时代精神中很流行，你知道的，一些机器学习技术被应用到了这些方面。这占了其中的大部分内容吗？还是说——我猜生物信息学的范围要广泛得多。你能跟我们讲讲这个领域具体是做什么的吗？当然可以。我想如果要我想一个通用的定义，那就是利用计算技术来分析生物学中的大型数据集。我可以举一些例子。所以，你知道，蛋白质折叠就是|||certainly one example. But the area that I focused on and that I actually worked on in industry for my first couple of companies was analyzing DNA sequencing data coming off of a sequencer. Basically, the idea is, you know, you sequence someone's DNA and you get a bunch of letters out of it, you know, A's, T's, C's, and G's. But how do you figure out what those letters actually mean? How do you figure out where a gene is and if this person has a mutation in that gene? And then once you figure out if there's a mutation, how do you devise computational methods to figure out if that mutation actually causes any effect to the person's health? For example, does that DNA mutation actually lead to a different protein being produced? And will that|||其中一个例子。但我关注的领域，也是我在前几家公司实际从事的工业界领域，是分析从测序仪中输出的 DNA 测序数据。基本上，这个想法是，你知道的，你对某人的 DNA 进行测序，然后从中得到一堆字母，你知道的，A、T、C 和 G。但是你如何弄清楚这些字母实际代表什么意思呢？你如何找出基因在哪里，以及这个人该基因是否有突变？然后，一旦你弄清楚是否存在突变，你如何设计计算方法来弄清楚该突变是否确实对这个人的健康产生了影响？例如，这种 DNA 突变是否真的会导致产生不同的蛋白质？这会|||be harmful to the person? So these are some of the things that I worked on for a few years and I would say are part of bioinformatics as well, is basically, you know, we're getting so much data off of DNA sequencers now that you can no longer analyze it by hand. And so you have to create computational methods to figure out how to make sense of this data at scale. That's awesome. I have this, like, I guess I'll share it publicly, even though it's still fresh in my mind, but always best to do it on a podcast where everyone can listen to it. I think like this, so this thing you're talking about DNA sequencing, I recently fell into some YouTube sort of raffle about DNA synthesis and how actually like it's accessible even for people at you know, at home, I guess, but like semi sophisticated. And so it fell in this whole rabbit hole of like plasmid engineering and like inserting your own sort of DNA synthesis that you designed into like E. coli or into yeast, and then sort of like having the expression of certain proteins,|||对这个人有害吗？所以这些是我工作了几年的其中一些事情，我想这也是生物信息学的一部分，基本上就是，你知道的，我们现在从 DNA 测序仪中获得的数据太多了，你再也无法靠人工来进行分析了。因此，你必须创建计算方法来弄清楚如何在大规模下理解这些数据。太棒了。我有这样一种——我想我会公开分享它，尽管它仍然在我脑海中挥之不去，但在每个人都可以听得到的播客上分享总是最好的。我觉得像这样，你刚才谈到的关于 DNA 测序的事情，我最近陷入了 YouTube 上关于 DNA 合成的某种抽奖活动中，以及实际上它是如何甚至可以让（你知道的）在家里的普通人接触到的，不过是半复杂的。于是我陷入了这样一个深不见底的技术黑洞，比如质粒工程，比如将你设计好的 DNA 合成片段插入到大肠杆菌或酵母中，然后某种程度上让某些蛋白质表达出来，|||either glow in the dark proteins, or even things that are components of milk or whatever be expressed via this like technique where like you said it blew my mind when they opened up this editor and they were showing like genes and copying and pasting from open source almost like i guess what we do for stack overflow no we don't definitely copy code from stack overflow they were copying various open source you know genes into these plasmids checking. It had like a linter equivalent, but then they would open up one of these and it's literally just the letters, right? It's just, and they could go in and make slight tweaks because some equivalencies are, they matter, but you can swap them. And it just like, it got me super excited until I realized just how much like time,|||比如发光蛋白质，甚至是通过这种技术表达的牛奶成分或其他东西，就像你说的，当他们打开这个编辑器并展示基因，从开源代码库复制粘贴时，我的脑洞大开——差不多就像我们在 Stack Overflow 上做的那样，不，我们绝对没有从 Stack Overflow 上复制代码——他们将各种开源的（你知道的）基因复制到这些质粒中并进行检查。它有类似 linter（代码检查工具）的东西，但随后他们打开其中一个，字面意思上它就只是字母，对吧？它就只是字母，他们可以进去做一些微小的调整，因为有些等价关系很重要，但你可以替换它们。这让我超级兴奋，直到我意识到需要花多少时间，|||because I know nothing about biology. So to go from like where I am to like making mine glow in the dark bread is a very big leap. Yeah, it's incredible. Actually, it's it's really exciting to see. In my opinion, one of the most exciting things is that this space is now open to people who are not, you know, bench scientists. So you can be a computational person and you can contribute to the bioinformatics space in ways like you were doing or by designing more efficient algorithms or even more software-oriented solutions|||因为我对生物学一无所知。所以从我现在的水平跨越到做出会让面包在黑暗中发光的程度，是一个非常巨大的飞跃。是的，这太不可思议了。实际上，看到这些真的让人很兴奋。在我看来，最令人兴奋的事情之一就是，这个领域现在向那些不是（你知道的）实验室科学人员开放了。所以你可以是一个从事计算的人才，你可以通过像你刚才所做的方式，或者通过设计更高效的算法，甚至是通过更倾向于软件的解决方案来为生物信息学领域做出贡献，|||like better parsing libraries to parse and create the text file formats that are used to share DNA sequencing information or coming up with a more efficient text-based representation of that data. So it's actually really exciting to see all the progress going on there. It is. I was excited to learn that I kind of, I guess, cynically assumed most of that software would be horrendously expensive. And it turns out now most of it you can kind of just like get, you know, it's just like open source, or the company that does a synthesis will provide it for free or whatever. So that got me kind of excited, too. So you came|||比如更好的解析库来解析和创建用于共享 DNA 测序信息的文本文件格式，或者想出一种更高效的基于文本的数据表示方法。所以看到那里的所有进展真的让人非常兴奋。确实如此。我很兴奋地了解到——我以前可能有点悲观地认为大部分此类软件会贵得离谱。结果现在大部分软件你基本上都可以直接获取，你知道的，它就像开源软件一样，或者负责合成的公司会免费提供它之类。所以这我也感到有点兴奋。那么你从|||out of you said, undergrad and master's studying bioinformatics. And then, you know, obviously, that time comes, you decide, I guess, to either go into academia or to go find a, I don't want to say a real job, but go find a job outside of academia. And where did you kind of end up? Yeah, I agonized a lot about whether to go back for a PhD program in something like computer science or bioinformatics or whether to go to industry. I decided to go to industry first and sort of try out the type of job that I would do after getting a PhD to see if I even liked it. So I started a company that was working on basically DNA sequencing technologies and providing a commercial product to patients to let them know if they had a hereditary risk for cancer or if there were a carrier of a hereditary disease that they might pass on to their children. mix of standard, you know, full stack software engineering, as well as some bioinformatics and|||你刚才说的，本科和硕士都学习生物信息学。然后，你知道的，显然时候到了，我猜你决定要么进入学术界，要么去找一份——我不想说是一份真正的工作，但就是去找一份学术界之外的工作。你最终去了哪里？是的，我曾非常痛苦地纠结于是回去攻读计算机科学或生物信息学之类的博士学位，还是直接去工业界。我决定先去工业界，尝试一下如果我拿到博士学位后会做的那种工作，看看自己究竟是不是真的喜欢它。所以我创办了一家公司，主要从事 DNA 测序技术，并向患者提供商业产品，让他们知道自己是否有遗传性癌症风险，或者是否是可能会遗传给孩子的遗传病的携带者。其中结合了标准的（你知道的）全栈软件工程，以及一些生物信息学和|||data analysis work. So that was a good role for me to sort of try out both opportunities and see what I liked. And I think over the years, I figured out that I actually really like software engineering. I find working in the healthcare space to be very meaningful and motivating for me. I've always wanted to work on something that was important to me and something that I thought could hopefully make life a little bit better for other people. So over time, I started thinking that maybe I want to be a software engineer, but still focused on something in the healthcare space. And I was interested in finding a pure software company that I felt could move a little faster, like software companies can. I think that sort of more of the biotech, bioinformatics companies are|||数据分析工作。所以对我来说，这是一个很好的角色，可以让我尝试这两种机会，看看自己喜欢什么。我想多年来，我发现自己其实真的很喜欢软件工程。我发现医疗健康领域的工作对我来说非常有意义且充满动力。我一直想从事对我很重要的事情，以及那些我认为有望让其他人的生活变得更好一点的事情. 所以随着时间的推移，我开始考虑也许我想成为一名软件工程师，但仍然专注于医疗健康领域的某些事情。并且我有兴趣找一家纯软件公司，我觉得它能行动得快一点，就像软件公司那样。我觉得那种生物技术、生物信息学公司往往|||very, very interesting, technically. But sometimes as a software engineer, it could feel a little bit slower since you're sort of only moving at the pace of science, if that makes sense. And, you know, you can't force scientific progress forward and it takes a lot of money to spin up a lab and pass regulations and that type of thing. And so I was looking for somewhere where I could ship software a lot faster, but still make an impact on the healthcare system. Yeah, I think this thing that you mentioned, interesting, is not only found in the healthcare kind of fields or biofields. Like, there's a big difference between working at a place where software is the main product, I guess, and something else is the main product. And I previously had worked somewhere|||在技术上非常非常有趣。但有时作为一名软件工程师，你可能会觉得节奏有点慢，因为你基本上只能以科学的速度前进，如果这说得通的话。而且，你知道的，你无法强行推动科学进步，建立实验室并通过法规等等需要花很多钱。所以我一直在寻找一个地方，在那里我可以更快地发布软件，但仍然对医疗保健系统产生影响。是的，我觉得你提到的这件有趣的事情，不仅在医疗健康领域或生物领域存在。比如，在以软件为主营产品的地方工作，和以其他东西为主营产品的地方工作，这两者之间有很大的区别。我以前曾在某个地方工作过，|||where software was a big part, but not the only part. And then switching to a company where software is the whole part is just a very different approach. I think we need software engineers in both or everywhere, I guess. But yeah, there is this, for I guess, coloring the conversation for people out there thinking about career choices, there really is a difference. I won't say one is better than the other because sometimes when something else is the focus, the sort of cross-function are, are very engaging and entertaining, and even the ability to make a sort of very large difference, because the amount of code being produced, there might be a little bit smaller, so your impact can be pretty big. But as|||那里软件占很大一部分，但不是唯一部分。然后切换到一家软件占全部的公司，这完全是另一种截然不同的方法。我想我们在两边或到处都需要软件工程师。但是，是的，对于正在考虑职业选择的人们来说，这确实给谈话增添了一些色彩，它们之间确实存在差异。我不会说哪一个比另一个更好，因为有时当其他事情成为焦点时，跨职能的协作会非常引人入胜且有趣，甚至能够产生非常巨大的影响，因为所编写的代码量可能稍微少一点，所以你的影响力可能会相当大。但正如|||you kind of alluded to, maybe maybe in some of those companies, you're limited by science, or by like the turn time of the iteration cycle, like you may be able to iterate your software, you're limited by science, or by like the turn time of the iteration cycle, like you may be able to iterate your software, you know, continuous delivery, you may every day have a new version of the software, but you know, hardware cycles are such that it takes, you know, things have to be produced or made six months, you know, a year, and that can be a challenge. And so I think that observation is, is very astute that's like this difference between a software first company and, you know, also software thing. And so you look to transition from the company doing the sequencing to a software company. And then that sounds like it wasn't it's not your role now, not to spoil it, but it sounds like you're getting closer. Yeah, actually. So first of all, I think you make a great point that I think we do need software engineers in all of the different aspects. And I certainly don't mean|||你刚才所暗示的，也许在其中某些公司中，你会受到科学的限制，或者受到迭代周期的周转时间的限制，比如你可能能够迭代你的软件，你受到科学的限制，或者受到迭代周期的周转时间的限制，比如你可能能够迭代你的软件，你知道的，持续交付，你可能每天都有一个新版本的软件，但你知道的，硬件周转周期就是这样，它需要——你知道的，有些东西必须生产或制造出来需要六个月，你知道的，一年，这可能是一个挑战。所以我认为这个观察非常敏锐，这就是软件优先公司和（你知道的）非纯软件公司之间的区别。所以你寻求从那家做测序的公司转型到一家软件公司。听起来这还不是你现在的角色——剧透一下，但听起来你越来越接近了。是的，实际上。首先，我觉得你提出了一个很好的观点，我认为我们在各个不同的方面确实都需要软件工程师。我当然不是指|||to say that one is better than the other. I think for me, so I actually did two companies first that were more focused on sequencing and analyzing the data coming off of the sequencer and delivering, you know, actionable results to patients. And I left that feeling like it was very interesting, but I just wanted to try a pure software company so that I knew what both sides of the coin looked like. And so actually after those two jobs that were focused on, you know, more on bioinformatics work, that's how I ended up at Akasa, where I'm at now. And I joined Akasa when we were maybe five or so full-time employees. And I was one of the very early software engineers. So that was also a really exciting experience to, you know,|||哪个比哪个更好。对我的经历来说，我其实先后在两家公司工作过，这两家公司更专注于测序、分析测序仪输出的数据，并向患者交付（你知道的）可付诸行动的结果。我离开时觉得那非常有趣，但我只是想尝试一下纯软件公司，这样我就能知道硬币的两面是什么样的。所以实际上，在经历了那两份更专注于生物信息学工作的职位之后，我才来到了我现在所在的 Akasa。我加入 Akasa 时，公司大概只有五名左右的全职员工。我是早期极少数的软件工程师之一。所以这也是一段非常令人兴奋的经历，你知道的，|||join at the beginning and help build the initial versions of the product while we were just trying to get product market fit and then see how much it's grown since then. Oh, wow. So yeah, I think it's always interesting. So like only five people working there. That's pretty tough. Like I guess like that's, you're not one of the people, it doesn't sound like you were the kind of group of people founding the company, which I kind of get that. And then the big company, but that those first few people, did you know some of the people who had founded the company? Or were you just like so convinced by their pits that like you were won over? I did. I knew one of our co-founders, our VP of engineering from my first job. And, you0|||在最初阶段加入，帮助构建产品的初始版本，当时我们正努力寻找产品市场契合点（PMF），然后看着它自那以后成长了多少。哦，哇。所以，是的，我觉得这总是很有趣。只有五个人在那里工作。那挺艰难的。我猜，你并不是那种人——听起来你好像不是那种创立公司的核心团队成员，我挺理解这一点的。然后是大公司，但那最初的几个人，你认识创立公司的某些人吗? 还是你只是被他们的推销（pitch）彻底折服了，所以被赢得了信任？我认识。我认识我们的一位联合创始人、工程副总裁，他是我第一份工作时的同事。而且，|||you know, that was a big factor in leading me to join the company. Otherwise,|||你知道的，这是促使我加入公司的主要原因。否则，|||you know, it's very hard to get signal on a seed stage startup and know, you0|||你知道的，要在种子轮初创公司获得明确信号并知道——|||know if it's going to be successful or not, or know if you're going to enjoy working with the people. Because by definition, at that stage, there's very little product maturity, and you're kind of signing up to take a lot of risks if you join a company at that stage so at least knowing somebody personally who I who I liked and respected was really helpful I guess there's signal and knowing someone that you don't like as well it just might be it might be a different kind of signal exactly yeah oh that's awesome okay so you started early and then I imagine i i actually|||知道它是否会成功，或者知道你是否会喜欢和这些人一起工作，是非常困难的。因为根据定义，在那个阶段，产品成熟度非常低，如果你在那个阶段加入一家公司，基本上就是签署了要承担巨大风险的协议，所以至少能个人认识一个我喜欢且尊敬的人真的很有帮助。我想，认识一个你讨厌的人也是一种信号，只不过可能是另一种信号，完全是这样，哈哈。哦，太棒了。好的，你很早就开始了，然后我想象——我其实|||just uh confession time again i've never worked at like a small company i always worked at like very large companies i always think kind of like you're like it's something i i would i kind of in my mind feel one day i want to try and just experience the difference but how was it being at a company trying to kind of get the product out, find the fit, like, you know, probably build sales, all that kind of stuff as a software engineer? Like, what did you find the experience to be like? I found it to be really exciting and also a lot of responsibility, which was what I was looking for. So that was a good thing.|||又到了坦白时间，我从来没有在那种小公司工作过，我总是呆在非常大的公司。我总是想，就像你一样，这是某种——我心里某种程度上觉得有一天我想去尝试并体验一下这种差异。但是，作为一个软件工程师，身处一家试图把产品推向市场、寻找产品契合点、建立销售等等所有这些事情的公司里，感觉是怎样的呢？你觉得这段经历感觉如何？我发现这真的非常令人兴奋，同时也伴随着巨大的责任感，而这正是我一直在寻找的。所以这是一件好事。|||You know, in the early days, it was really just trying to build the first version of the product, get it in front of customers and get feedback and iterate quickly. I think that was the most important thing was to make sure that we could make changes quickly and speed up that iteration cycle of, you know, getting feedback and putting another rev on the product, getting it in front of customers again. And at the beginning, I think we were really in the sort of do things that don't scale phase, which even if it takes a ton of effort to make one customer happy, it's totally worth it. And we just wanted to prove that we could provide value. And once we did that, repeatedly, you know, two or three times, then we started to think about basically how to replicate this and how to be able to turn it on with less effort. And also, you know, a non-trivial challenge is also how to bring on more people onto the team and, you know, sort of give them a template for how we do our work and how they can, you know, take|||你知道的，在早期阶段，真的只是试图构建产品的第一个版本，把它放到客户面前，获取反馈并快速迭代。我认为最重要的是确保我们能够快速做出改变，并加快那个迭代周期——你知道的，获取反馈，对产品进行又一次修订，再次把它放到客户面前。在刚开始的时候，我觉得我们真的处于那种“做无法规模化的事情”的阶段，即使花费大量的精力去让一个客户满意，也是完全值得的。我们只是想证明我们能够提供价值。一旦我们这样做了，重复了两三次，你知道的，然后我们才开始思考基本上如何复制这一点，以及如何能够以更小的精力和成本来启动它。而且，你知道的，一个不小的挑战也是如何将更多的人引入团队，以及，你知道的，给他们一个模板，说明我们是如何工作的，以及他们如何能够，你知道的，|||a customer and go make a new customer happy using the tools that we provided. I think that is a really good observation. I was having a very related conversation with people at work, several people about what you're saying, which is there's a difference between having more work that needs to be done. And like, having stuff set up in a way so that like the work needing to be done can be solved by bringing more people on. And it was like a very wordy, I need to come up with a catchier way of saying it, I guess. But like, this thing about the rotation of, you know, how things are built and done that going from, I have 1000 tasks, but I'm the only person who can do them to I have 1000 tasks, but|||利用我们提供的工具去服务一个客户并让一个新客户满意。我认为这是一个非常好的观察。我最近在工作中与几个人进行过一次非常相关的谈话，内容就是你所说的，也就是：有更多需要完成的工作，这与——以一种方式将事情设置好，从而可以通过引入更多人来解决需要完成的工作，这两者之间是有区别的。这话说得很啰嗦，我想我得想个更引人注目的说法。但是，关于事情如何构建和完成的这种流转，即从“我有 1000 个任务，但我是唯一能做这些事情的人”转变到“我有 1000 个任务，但|||they're organized in such a way that like, I can effectively communicate to others, like, how that we can, you know, efficiently combine our powers together in a, in a, you know, cooperative way, rather than just stepping on each other's toes or constantly accidentally doing the same work. And so I think that thing you mentioned about thinking about the work in a way that you could hand it and describe it to someone new so they can replicate it is a challenge I don't hear talked about a lot. Yeah, absolutely. Have you read that famous essay called The Mythical Man Month? Have you heard of that? I do know about it. I do know what the theory says, but I haven't actually read it.|||它们被组织成这样，我可以有效地与其他人沟通，比如我们如何能够（你知道的）以一种合作的方式高效地结合我们的力量，而不是互相踩脚或者不断地意外重复做同样的工作。所以我认为你提到的那种思考工作的方式——即你可以将工作交接并描述给新人，以便他们能够复制——是我不常听到人们讨论的一个挑战。是的，绝对如此。你读过那篇著名的文章《人月神话》（The Mythical Man Month）吗？你听说过吗？我知道它。我知道这个理论说的是什么，但我实际上并没有读过它。|||I guess this will be my conviction to have to go read it after this. Yeah, it's a good read. And it's pretty short. And I often recommend that people on my team or new people who join the company read it because I think it talks about exactly this problem where, you know, you have a team of two or three people, and they're doing really well. And then you want to make them be able to do more. So the first instinct is, you know, what happens if we double the team, we should expect twice the output, right? But that turns out not to be right due to|||我想这会成为我的信念，逼着我在聊完之后去读一读。是的，这是一本好书。而且它相当短。我经常推荐我团队中的人或加入公司的新人去读它，因为我觉得它探讨的正是这个问题，你知道的，你有一个两三人的团队，他们做得很好。然后你想让他们能够做更多的事情。所以第一直觉是，你知道的，如果我们把团队人数翻倍会怎么样，我们应该期望产出翻倍，对吧？但事实证明这是不对的，因为|||onboarding and communication overhead and people not knowing exactly what their responsibilities are. And yeah, I think that that's a big part of technical leadership actually is figuring out how to set up projects in a way that you can effectively bring new people onto the project and make sure that they're productive and they have enough runway. And you want to avoid that N squared communication problem where everybody has to talk with everybody else in order to figure out what their integration points are. Ideally, you want to make sure that people know exactly what they're building and someone has sort of planned it up front. So it's all going to fit together if everyone builds it correctly. All right. I have it. I wrote it down. I'm adding it. I feel called out. It's a classic. I know it's been recommended and I've been lazy. So to the topic though, you were mentioning doing a lot of things that don't scale and just getting it done. And not necessarily, I don't want to say|||入职和沟通开销，以及人们不清楚自己的具体职责是什么。是的，我认为这其实是技术领导力的很大一部分，那就是弄清楚如何以这样一种方式来设置项目：你可以有效地将新人引入项目，确保他们能够高产并拥有足够的起步跑道。你希望避免那种 N 平方的沟通问题，即每个人都必须与其他人交流，以便弄清楚他们的集成点是什么。理想情况下，你希望确保每个人都确切地知道他们在构建什么，并且有人已经提前规划好了。所以如果每个人都正确构建，它们就会完美契合。好吧。我有这本书。我写下来了。我把它加上。我感觉被点名了。这是一部经典之作。我知道它一直被推荐，而我太懒了。不过回到正题，你刚才提到做了很多无法规模化的事情，并且只是把事情做完。并且不一定——我不想说|||getting it done right is a second thing, but just getting it done. And not necessarily, I don't want to say getting it done right is a second thing, but just getting it done in a way that gets it out, gets the feedback, gets the cycle started, you know, getting iterations and these kinds of things. I got to imagine like at that time, a lot of the work is you might step in and do it yourself rather than, you know, trying to write the software that you know you should write to do it. Is that kind of well describing of what was happening at the time? Yeah, that's right. You know, initially, when you're just trying to test the value of something, you want a|||把事情做好是第二位的，但求把事情做完。并且不一定——我不想说把事情做好是第二位的，而是说把事情做完，并以一种能把它发布出去、获取反馈、让周期运转起来的方式去做，你知道的，进行迭代以及诸如此类的事情。我可以想象，在那个时候，很多工作可能是你亲自介入并自己去做，而不是去（你知道的）试图编写你明知应该编写来做这件事的软件。这很好地描述了当时的情况吗？是的，没错。你知道的，最初，当你只是想测试某样东西的价值时，你需要一个|||cheap prototype before you invest a ton of effort in automating it. So sometimes it would be, you know, testing something manually and just, just seeing if it would even work if we, if we built a computer program to automate it. Or, you know, sometimes, you know, before we invested in fully automatic CICD and, you know, deployments running all around the clock. You know, it would just be, what if I run this once a day manually and see how much work it picks up and see if it can do the job for our customers. And then, you know, once we get past that phase where it's clear that the solution is providing value, then it makes sense to really invest in it as a fully automated solution. I think that is a, I don't want to say, I think when we have software only companies, sometimes that bit of difference in big companies,|||低成本的原型，然后再投入大量精力去将其自动化。所以有时情况会是，你知道的，手动测试某些东西，然后看看如果我们编写一个计算机程序来将其自动化，它是否真的行得通。或者，你知道的，有时，在我们投入全自动的 CI/CD 以及（你知道的）全天候运行的 deployment 之前。你知道的，可能只是：如果我每天手动运行一次这个程序，看看它能接手多少工作，看看它能否为我们的客户完成这项工作，会怎么样？然后，你知道的，一旦我们度过了那个阶段，即很明显该解决方案正在提供价值，那么作为完全自动化的解决方案真正投资它就很有意义了。我认为这是一个——我不想说，我认为当我们拥有纯软件公司时，大公司中那种细微的差异有时|||at least I've seen gets missed, which is people just go straight to the glamorous solution that sounds really awesome, right? And so you end up building this big infrastructure that has a lot of latency from when you go to start to when it's ready to be done. And then you deliver it and then it gets used once or twice. And it's bit rots and you know, all these problems and then it just the payout wasn't worth the investment. And so I think that this way you describe it of sometimes just biting the bullet and kind of getting it out making sure that it gets used once or twice is is really annoying. You have to do|||至少我看到被忽略了，那就是人们直接奔向那个听起来真的很棒的光鲜亮丽的解决方案，对吧？所以你最终构建了这个庞大的基础设施，从你开始着手到它准备就绪，存在大量的延迟。然后你交付了它，结果它只被使用了一两次。然后它就代码腐烂了（bit rot），你知道的，所有这些问题随之而来，接着回报根本不值得投资。所以我认为你所描述的这种方式——有时只是咬紧牙关，把它推出来，确保它被使用一两次——真的很烦人。你必须做|||this thing once a day. But yeah, I think that's such a great way to get a minimally viable product out, get feedback on it, and not on the whole product, but even on just like little bits of functionality. Yeah, absolutely. And especially at a startup, inherently, you have limited resources, and there's a lot of opportunity cost. As a startup, you're trying to prove|||这件事每天一次。但是，是的，我觉得这真是推出最小可行性产品（MVP）、获取其反馈的一个绝佳方法，不仅是对整个产品，甚至只是对一小部分功能。是的，绝对如此。尤其是在一家初创公司里，本质上你的资源是有限的，并且存在着巨大的机会成本。作为一家初创公司，你正在努力证明|||yourself and you're trying to make money and do it with a small team. And so if you spend three months or six months building some glamorous solution and it turns out that customers don't like it, then you're actually just wasted really valuable resources and more importantly, wasted time and wasted some of your social capital with that customer as well. So you guys are working at the startup in the, we haven't really said, but like in the healthcare space and you're talking about customers, what is kind of the flow of stuff you guys are working on looks like? Like what is it that you're trying to do to get out in front of people? Yeah, absolutely. So basically, ACASA's goal here is to help hospitals that end up having a ton of manual human repetitive work, you know, often centered around working with health insurance|||你自己，你正试图赚钱，并且靠一个小团队来做到这一点。所以如果你花三六个月的时间去构建某种光鲜亮丽的解决方案，结果发现客户根本不喜欢它，那么你实际上只是浪费了非常宝贵的资源，更重要的是，浪费了时间，也浪费了你在该客户那里的部分社会资本。所以你们在医疗健康领域的初创公司工作——我们之前没怎么提过，但就像在医疗健康领域一样——当你们谈到客户时，你们正在从事的工作流程大概是怎样的？比如你们究竟在努力做些什么来呈现在人们面前？是的，绝对如此。所以基本上，ACASA 在这里的目标是帮助那些最终拥有大量人工重复性工作的医院，你知道的，这些工作通常围绕着与健康保险公司的合作展开。|||companies. And, you know, the health healthcare industry is super complex. So hospitals have hundreds or thousands of workflows that they're running, and they basically have humans serving all of these every day. So our goal is to build an end-to-end automation. So learn what a human does at a hospital system, figure out all the manual and repetitive tasks that they're doing, and then build a computer program that can completely automate it end to end. And so, you know, we often start by carving out specific pieces of what we call the revenue cycle management or medical billing. So for example, carving out a product where humans are paid to check the status of a claim that the hospital submitted to the insurance|||而且，你知道的，医疗健康行业超级复杂。因此，医院运行着成百上千个工作流，并且他们基本上每天都让人工来处理所有这些工作流。所以我们的目标是构建端到端的自动化。也就是了解人类在医院系统中做的事情，弄清楚他们正在做的所有手动和重复性任务，然后构建一个能够将其完全端到端自动化的计算机程序。所以，你知道的，我们通常从切分我们称之为收入周期管理（RCM）或医疗计费的特定部分开始。例如，切分出一个产品，让员工拿着薪水去检查医院提交给保险公司的理赔申请的状态，|||company a month or two ago, but didn't get paid for. Or humans are paid to look at every denied claim that comes through and decide if it can be fixed and resubmitted to the hospital or to the insurance company and have that revenue recouped. And so basically, Akasa's idea here is, you know, effectively enterprise software company, helping hospitals automate a lot of the manual work that they have to do today. I think like, I want to come back, I want to come back to Akasa here in a minute. But but to kind of like, I see now, okay, so you guys are looking to automate these processes.|||那个理赔是一个或两个月前提交的，但还没有拿到钱。或者付钱让人工去查看每一个被拒绝的理赔申请，并决定是否可以将其修复并重新提交给医院或保险公司，从而追回这笔收入。所以基本上，Akasa 这里的想法是，你知道的，实际上就是一家企业级软件公司，帮助医院自动化他们今天必须做的许多人工工作。我觉得，我想回来——我一会儿想回到 Akasa。但是为了——我明白了，好吧，所以你们正着手将这些流程自动化。|||I think this sounds like not even all that specific to healthcare. There are things even just in software engineering day-to-day that I do by hand and think about automating. So you guys are kind of taking, trying to understand which of those matter, how do you do them? And you're sort of going through and finding, there's this sort of, not to spoil, but there's sort of a big pipeline of stuff that flows from, you know, sort of inputs to something at the end. Maybe there's cycles in it, maybe there's not.|||我觉得这听起来甚至没有那么局限于医疗健康领域。有些事情甚至在软件工程的日常中，我也会手动去做并考虑将其自动化。所以你们正在采取的做法是，试图理解其中哪些是重要的，你们是怎么做这些事的？你们在经历并发现，这里有某种——剧透一下，这类似于一条庞大的管道，其中的东西从（你知道的）某种输入流向末端的东西。也许其中有循环，也许没有。|||Hint, we're teeing up some future discussion here. But at the beginning, there are all these things where there are effectively humans or manual processes sort of getting the ball rolling. And so you're starting by figuring out where those are and trying to automate them. Yeah, that's exactly right. And you're actually alluding to something really good, which is everything we've built in our platform is completely generic. So we've been pretty intentional about this as a company. And we sort of structure the company in terms of the platform arm and then the integrations arm. And on the platform side, everything we've built is totally generic. And you could really use it to automate almost any task that you can do on a computer. We've started|||提示一下，我们正在为以后的讨论做铺垫。但在开始的时候，所有这些事情实际上都是靠人类或人工流程来让事情运转起来的。所以你们首先要找出这些环节在哪里，并试图将其自动化。是的，完全正确。而且你实际上在暗示一件非常好的事情，那就是我们在平台上构建的一切都是完全通用的。所以作为一家公司，我们在这一点上是非常有意的。我们将公司结构化为平台部门，然后是集成部门。在平台端，我们构建的一切都是完全通用的。你真的可以用它来自动化你能在计算机上几乎完成的任何任务。我们开始|||out by focusing in revenue cycle management, or again, medical billing, because it turns out that there's just a ton of manual repetitive work that happens in that industry. But in the future, we could totally take our platform and, you know, go help customers and almost any industry that has a lot of manual work, because we've built our platform in a generic way. So I guess in thinking about, in the generic sense, I guess, thinking about this task automation and doing these things, I guess one place where I see humans step in is when you're going between two systems|||时专注于收入周期管理，或者说医疗计费，因为事实证明，那个行业中存在着大量的手动重复工作。但在未来，我们完全可以拿着我们的平台，（你知道的）去帮助几乎任何拥有大量手工工作的行业的客户，因为我们是以通用方式构建平台的。所以我想在思考时——在通用意义上，我想，在思考这种任务自动化和做这些事情时，我发现人类介入的一个地方是当你在两个系统之间切换时，|||that don't have a good way of communicating. And then the other thing I'll think about, but I don't know that we'll talk too much about that is like sort of sensory related like oh i want i need the thing to count the number of humans that come in this door or whatever where you might need to solve a sort of bigger problem that i don't know is as generic you know or you're trying to sense something in the real world where you might ask a human to do it trivially and then put it into the computer but i think this i i don't know if kind of which you sort of fall on, but I've seen both cases. But this case, even just from one system,|||而这两个系统没有良好的沟通方式。另一件我会考虑的事情是——但我不知道我们是否会对此谈论太多——类似于感官相关的事情，比如“哦，我想要——我需要某个东西来计算进出这扇门的人数”之类的事情，在这些情况下，你可能需要解决某种更大的问题，我不知道它是否像那样通用，你知道的，或者你正试图感知现实世界中的某些东西，你可能会要求人类轻而易举地完成它，然后将其输入计算机。但我认为这——我不知道你更倾向于哪一种，但我两种情况都见过。但这种情况，甚至只是从一个系统，|||I have something in an Excel sheet and I need it in a SQL database. And it's like, yeah, I probably could find a tool to do that, but I could also just like, you know, write it myself. Yeah, exactly. And I think we focus more on that former end. So it's a couple of things. One is coordination between systems, like you mentioned. So healthcare software is complex. The insurance companies are running their own software systems. Hospitals are running their own electronic health record systems. And one of the big problems is effectively synchronization|||我有 Excel 表格里的一些东西，我需要把它放进 SQL 数据库中。这就好像是，是的，我大概能找到一个工具来做这件事，但我也可以——你知道的，自己写一个。是的，完全正确。而且我认为我们更多地专注于前面那端。所以这是几件事。一是系统之间的协调，就像你提到的那样。所以医疗保健软件很复杂。保险公司运行着他们自己的软件系统。医院运行着他们自己的电子病历系统。其中一个大问题实际上是同步，|||between all these systems. So, you know, hospital submits a claim and they wait a month or two and they don't hear back from the insurance company. So they're effectively paying someone to go into the hospital system, which we call the electronic health record, grab all the information about that claim, open up a web browser, go to the health insurance company's website, type in the information about this claim, click, you know, where's my claim, get a web page back, read that web page to understand the status of the claim, and then go back to the electronic health record system and update the status of the claim accordingly. And so this is an example of a very simple revenue cycle workflow. And we can basically automate all parts|||所有这些系统之间的同步。所以，你知道的，医院提交了一份理赔申请，然后等了一两个月却没有收到保险公司的回复。所以他们实际上是在付钱让人工进入医院系统（我们称之为电子病历），抓取关于该理赔的所有信息，打开网页浏览器，进入健康保险公司的网站，输入关于这个理赔的信息，点击（你知道的）“我的理赔在哪里”，获取一个返回的网页，阅读该网页以了解理赔的状态，然后返回电子病历系统并相应地更新理赔的状态。这就是一个非常简单的收入周期工作流的例子。我们基本上可以自动化所有这些部分
be succinct, but also precise when you communicate with other software engineers. If you don't know what I'm talking about design patterns, I think we have an episode on them. If not, definitely Google them up and take a look at them. But I think there are other, not captured by necessarily design patterns themselves, but other concepts,
与其他软件工程师沟通时，要做到简明扼要，同时又要精确。如果你不知道我在说什么设计模式，我想我们有一集是关于这个的。如果没有，一定要去谷歌搜索一下并看一看。但我觉得还有一些其他的东西，不一定包含在设计模式本身中，而是其他一些概念，
which once you start doing practical, real world software engineering, you start to run into recurring issues. We've talked about some of them that get addressed for things like continuous integration, continuous deployment. The reason why we talk about those are because it's something that comes up again and again.
一旦你开始进行实际的、真实的软件工程，你就会开始遇到反复出现的问题。我们已经讨论过其中一些可以通过持续集成、持续部署等方式解决的问题。我们之所以讨论这些，是因为它们是一次又一次出现的事情。
When people don't do those things, they run into this set of problems. And it's not the only solution, but it's a recurring and good solution. And so today we're going to talk about some things in that same vein. And here with us today, we have Sanjay Sadante, Director of Engineering at Acasa. Welcome to the show, Sanjay. Thank you. Thanks for having me. Awesome. Well, we always love to start by learning a bit about how people got to where they are. I think life story is just kind of that interesting thing. Maybe it's because I've grown a little more
当人们不做这些事情时，他们就会陷入这一系列问题中。这不是唯一的解决方案，但它是一个反复出现且不错的解决方案。所以今天我们将讨论一些同样方向的事情。今天和我们在一起的是Sanjay Sadante，Acasa的工程总监。欢迎来到节目，Sanjay。谢谢。谢谢邀请我。太棒了。嗯，我们总是喜欢通过了解人们是如何走到今天这一步来开始。我觉得生活故事就是那种有趣的事情。也许是因为我变得更成熟了一点，
mature, a little older. I like hearing how people also have their own journey and also to just sort of learn the diverse ways people end up in jobs is always just fascinating to me because when people always give career advice, there's always like this one way you do things and it's the way they did things. And so I like hearing that breadth. And so do you have, some people do, some people don't. Do you remember kind of like the first time you either like did programming or your first piece of tech or what got you really excited about this field? Yeah, absolutely. I think the first time I programmed a computer was in eighth grade, and I built a simple website just using HTML and CSS. I didn't even use JavaScript at the time,
年纪大了一点。我喜欢听人们也有他们自己的旅程，也只是为了解人们以各种不同的方式最终找到工作，对我和我来说总是很迷人，因为当人们总是给出职业建议时，总是有一种你做事的方式，这就是他们做事的方式。所以我喜欢听到这种广度。那么你有吗，有些人有，有些人没有。你还记得你第一次编程或者你的第一件科技产品，或者是什么真正让你对这个领域感到兴奋吗？是的，绝对的。我想我第一次给计算机编程是在八年级，我只用HTML和CSS建立了一个简单的网站。当时我甚至没有使用JavaScript，
and I really liked it. And so all through high school, I ended up building a lot of websites and taking AP computer science. So learned a bit of Java. And I came into college with, I'd say, a fair amount of programming experience and pretty sure that I wanted to major in computer science. Awesome. I also took AP computer science and also did Java. But I'm not curious if they still, do you know you know they still teach it in Java? I'm curious if they've gone to something else. You know, I went back to visit the AP Computer Science class at my first, I guess, academic exposures, but also had been programming a bit before. And so yeah, it's interesting, the web design and sort of so HTML, CSS, being able to, you wanted to do computer science, it sounds like. And then when you went to college, you continued to pursue it? Or did you try something else at first? I had a lot of interests going into college. So I was always taking computer science courses, but also a lot of math classes and also a lot of biology. And I wasn't totally sure how I wanted to mix all of these interests. I had, you know, one idea that I might go to medical school and, you know, be a computational person in that space.
我真的很喜欢它。所以在整个高中期间，我最终建立了很多网站并参加了AP计算机科学。所以学了一点Java。我带着相当多的编程经验进入大学，并且非常确定我想主修计算机科学。太棒了。我也参加了AP计算机科学并学了Java。但我不好奇他们是否还在，你知道他们是否还在用Java教吗？我很好奇他们是否改用别的了。你知道，我回去参观了我第一个计算机科学AP班，我想是我最初接触学术的地方，但之前也编过一点程。所以，是的，这很有趣，网页设计和某种HTML、CSS，能够，你想学计算机科学，听起来是这样。然后你上大学后继续深造了吗？还是你一开始尝试了别的？我上大学时有很多兴趣。所以我一直在上计算机科学课程，还有很多数学课和很多生物课。我并不是完全确定我想如何将所有这些兴趣结合起来。我有，你知道，一个想法，我可能会去医学院，你知道，成为那个领域的一个计算型人才。
And another idea that I might be a software engineer. So it took me a couple years in college to sort of figure out what I was interested in. And I would say, once I heard about bioinformatics for the first time, that's when I realized what I really wanted to do. Both my parents are scientists. And so growing up, I was always really interested in science. And we would talk about biology and chemistry at the dinner table. But I didn't ever realize that there were opportunities for computational folks to work on analyzing big data sets in that space. But once I found that in college, that's what I ended up focusing on for the rest of undergrad and for grad school.
另一个想法是我可能会成为一名软件工程师。所以我花了几年时间在大学里弄清楚我对什么感兴趣。我想说，当我第一次听说生物信息学时，我才意识到我真正想做的是什么。我的父母都是科学家。所以在成长过程中，我一直对科学很感兴趣。我们会在饭桌上谈论生物学和化学。但我从来没有意识到，在这个领域里，计算人才有机会从事分析大数据集的工作。但一旦我在大学里找到了这个，这就是我本科剩余时间和研究生阶段专注于的事情。
Oh, nice. So I know the term bioinformatics, and I guess using the prefix and suffix and your context, I could guess. And part of me thinks like things like gene folding, I guess, has been like popular recently in the zeitgeist of, you know, some of the machine learning techniques as applied to those. Is that like the bulk of it is stuff related to that? Or is it I assume it's much broader than that, bioinformatics. Can you maybe tell us a little bit about what did that field? Yeah, absolutely. I think if I had to think of a generic definition, it would be using computational techniques to analyze large data sets in biology. And I can give some examples. So, you know, protein folding is
哦，太棒了。所以我知道生物信息学这个词，我想用前缀和后缀结合你的上下文，我可以猜到。我的一部分想法是，比如基因折叠，我想，最近在机器学习技术应用于这些技术的时代精神中很受欢迎。这算是其中的大部分吗？还是我认为生物信息学要广泛得多？你能给我们讲讲那个领域是做什么的吗？是的，绝对的。我想如果我必须想一个通用的定义，那就是使用计算技术来分析生物学中的大型数据集。我可以举一些例子。所以，你知道，蛋白质折叠是
certainly one example. But the area that I focused on and that I actually worked on in industry for my first couple of companies was analyzing DNA sequencing data coming off of a sequencer. Basically, the idea is, you know, you sequence someone's DNA and you get a bunch of letters out of it, you know, A's, T's, C's, and G's. But how do you figure out what those letters actually mean? How do you figure out where a gene is and if this person has a mutation in that gene? And then once you figure out if there's a mutation, how do you devise computational methods to figure out if that mutation actually causes any effect to the person's health? For example, does that DNA mutation actually lead to a different protein being produced? And will that
当然是一个例子。但我关注的领域，也是我前几家公司在业界实际工作的领域，是分析从测序仪中提取的DNA测序数据。基本上，这个想法是，你知道，你对某人的DNA进行测序，然后从中得到一堆字母，你知道，A、T、C和G。但是你如何弄清楚这些字母实际意味着什么呢？你如何找出基因在哪里，这个人基因中是否有突变？然后，一旦你弄清楚是否存在突变，你如何设计计算方法来弄清楚这种突变是否真的对人的健康产生任何影响？例如，这种DNA突变是否真的导致产生不同的蛋白质？这会
be harmful to the person? So these are some of the things that I worked on for a few years and I would say are part of bioinformatics as well, is basically, you know, we're getting so much data off of DNA sequencers now that you can no longer analyze it by hand. And so you have to create computational methods to figure out how to make sense of this data at scale. That's awesome. I have this, like, I guess I'll share it publicly, even though it's still fresh in my mind, but always best to do it on a podcast where everyone can listen to it. I think like this, so this thing you're talking about DNA sequencing, I recently fell into some YouTube sort of raffle about DNA synthesis and how actually like it's accessible even for people at you know, at home, I guess, but like semi sophisticated. And so it fell in this whole rabbit hole of like plasmid engineering and like inserting your own sort of DNA synthesis that you designed into like E. coli or into yeast, and then sort of like having the expression of certain proteins,
对人有害吗？所以这些是我工作了几年的事情，我想这也是生物信息学的一部分，基本上，你知道，我们现在从DNA测序仪中获得的数据太多了，以至于你再也不能人工分析它了。所以你必须创建计算方法，以找出如何大规模理解这些数据。太棒了。我有这个，就像，我想我会公开分享它，尽管它仍然在我的脑海中很新鲜，但最好在每个人都可以收听的播客上进行。我想像这个，你谈论的DNA测序，我最近偶然发现了一些关于DNA合成的YouTube抽奖活动，以及实际上它甚至对家里的人来说是如何可以访问的，我想，但有点复杂。所以它陷入了质粒工程的整个兔子洞，比如将你设计的自己的DNA合成插入到大肠杆菌或酵母中，然后通过这种技术表达某些蛋白质，
either glow in the dark proteins, or even things that are components of milk or whatever be expressed via this like technique where like you said it blew my mind when they opened up this editor and they were showing like genes and copying and pasting from open source almost like i guess what we do for stack overflow no we don't definitely copy code from stack overflow they were copying various open source you know genes into these plasmids checking. It had like a linter equivalent, but then they would open up one of these and it's literally just the letters, right? It's just, and they could go in and make slight tweaks because some equivalencies are, they matter, but you can swap them. And it just like, it got me super excited until I realized just how much like time,
不管是发光的蛋白质，还是牛奶的成分或其他东西，都可以通过这种技术表达，正如你所说，当我打开这个编辑器并展示基因并从开源复制和粘贴时，这让我大开眼界，几乎就像我们对堆栈溢出所做的那样，不，我们绝对不从堆栈溢出复制代码，他们正在将各种开源基因复制到这些质粒中进行检查。它有一个类似linter的东西，但随后他们会打开其中一个，它实际上只是字母，对吧？它只是，他们可以进去做一些微小的调整，因为有些等价物很重要，但你可以交换它们。这让我超级兴奋，直到我意识到需要多少时间，
because I know nothing about biology. So to go from like where I am to like making mine glow in the dark bread is a very big leap. Yeah, it's incredible. Actually, it's it's really exciting to see. In my opinion, one of the most exciting things is that this space is now open to people who are not, you know, bench scientists. So you can be a computational person and you can contribute to the bioinformatics space in ways like you were doing or by designing more efficient algorithms or even more software-oriented solutions
因为我对生物学一无所知。所以从我现在的状态到让我的发光面包需要跨越非常大的一步。是的，太不可思议了。事实上，这真的很令人兴奋。在我看来，最令人兴奋的事情之一是，这个空间现在对不是板凳科学家的普通人开放了。所以你可以是一个计算人员，你可以通过你正在做的方式或通过设计更高效的算法甚至更多面向软件的解决方案来为生物信息学空间做出贡献，
like better parsing libraries to parse and create the text file formats that are used to share DNA sequencing information or coming up with a more efficient text-based representation of that data. So it's actually really exciting to see all the progress going on there. It is. I was excited to learn that I kind of, I guess, cynically assumed most of that software would be horrendously expensive. And it turns out now most of it you can kind of just like get, you know, it's just like open source, or the company that does a synthesis will provide it for free or whatever. So that got me kind of excited, too. So you came
比如更好的解析库，用于解析和创建用于共享DNA测序信息的文本文件格式，或者提出该数据更高效的基于文本的表示。所以看到那里发生的所有进展真的很令人兴奋。确实如此。我很兴奋地了解到我某种程度上，我想，愤世嫉俗地假设大部分软件都会贵得离谱。事实证明，现在大部分软件你都可以买到，你知道，它就像开源一样，或者做合成的公司会免费提供等等。所以这让我也有点兴奋。所以你出来了
out of you said, undergrad and master's studying bioinformatics. And then, you know, obviously, that time comes, you decide, I guess, to either go into academia or to go find a, I don't want to say a real job, but go find a job outside of academia. And where did you kind of end up? Yeah, I agonized a lot about whether to go back for a PhD program in something like computer science or bioinformatics or whether to go to industry. I decided to go to industry first and sort of try out the type of job that I would do after getting a PhD to see if I even liked it. So I started a company that was working on basically DNA sequencing technologies and providing a commercial product to patients to let them know if they had a hereditary risk for cancer or if there were a carrier of a hereditary disease that they might pass on to their children. mix of standard, you know, full stack software engineering, as well as some bioinformatics and
你说的是，本科和硕士学习生物信息学。然后，你知道，显然，那个时刻到来了，你决定，我想，要么去学术界，要么去找一个，我不想说一份真正的工作，而是去找一份学术界之外的工作。你最后到了哪里？是的，我很纠结是回去攻读计算机科学或生物信息学之类的博士学位，还是去工业界。我决定先去工业界，尝试一下攻读博士学位后我会做的工作类型，看看我是否真的喜欢它。所以我创办了一家公司，主要从事DNA测序技术的研究，并向患者提供商业产品，让他们知道他们是否有遗传性癌症风险，或者他们是否是可能传给孩子的遗传病的携带者。标准的全栈软件工程的混合，以及一些生物信息学和
data analysis work. So that was a good role for me to sort of try out both opportunities and see what I liked. And I think over the years, I figured out that I actually really like software engineering. I find working in the healthcare space to be very meaningful and motivating for me. I've always wanted to work on something that was important to me and something that I thought could hopefully make life a little bit better for other people. So over time, I started thinking that maybe I want to be a software engineer, but still focused on something in the healthcare space. And I was interested in finding a pure software company that I felt could move a little faster, like software companies can. I think that sort of more of the biotech, bioinformatics companies are
数据分析工作。所以对我来说，这是一个很好的角色，可以尝试这两个机会并看看我喜欢什么。我想这些年来，我发现我其实真的很喜欢软件工程。我觉得在医疗保健领域工作对我和我很有意义，也很激励我。我一直想从事对我来说很重要的事情，我觉得这有望让其他人的生活变得更好一点。所以随着时间的推移，我开始考虑也许我想成为一名软件工程师，但仍然专注于医疗保健领域的某些东西。而且我有兴趣寻找一家纯软件公司的感觉，我觉得它可以走得快一点，就像软件公司那样。我认为更多的生物技术、生物信息学公司是
very, very interesting, technically. But sometimes as a software engineer, it could feel a little bit slower since you're sort of only moving at the pace of science, if that makes sense. And, you know, you can't force scientific progress forward and it takes a lot of money to spin up a lab and pass regulations and that type of thing. And so I was looking for somewhere where I could ship software a lot faster, but still make an impact on the healthcare system. Yeah, I think this thing that you mentioned, interesting, is not only found in the healthcare kind of fields or biofields. Like, there's a big difference between working at a place where software is the main product, I guess, and something else is the main product. And I previously had worked somewhere
从技术上讲非常非常有趣。但有时作为一名软件工程师，感觉会慢一些，因为你只是以科学的速度前进，如果这说得通的话。而且，你知道，你不能强迫科学进步，建立实验室并通过法规需要花很多钱，诸如此类的事情。所以我在寻找一个我可以更快地交付软件，但仍然对医疗保健系统产生影响的地方。是的，我觉得你提到的这件有趣的事情，不仅在医疗保健或生物领域发现。比如，在软件是主要产品的地方工作，和在其他东西是主要产品的地方工作之间有很大的区别。我以前曾在某个地方工作过
where software was a big part, but not the only part. And then switching to a company where software is the whole part is just a very different approach. I think we need software engineers in both or everywhere, I guess. But yeah, there is this, for I guess, coloring the conversation for people out there thinking about career choices, there really is a difference. I won't say one is better than the other because sometimes when something else is the focus, the sort of cross-function are, are very engaging and entertaining, and even the ability to make a sort of very large difference, because the amount of code being produced, there might be a little bit smaller, so your impact can be pretty big. But as
软件是很大的一部分，但不是唯一的部分。然后换到软件是全部部分的公司，这是一种非常不同的方法。我认为我们在两边或无处不在都需要软件工程师，我想。但是的，这确实存在，对于那些考虑职业选择的人来说，确实有区别。我不会说一个比另一个更好，因为有时当其他事情是焦点时，跨职能是非常吸引人和有趣的，甚至能够产生非常大的差异，因为生成的代码量可能有点小，所以你的影响可以相当大。但正如
you kind of alluded to, maybe maybe in some of those companies, you're limited by science, or by like the turn time of the iteration cycle, like you may be able to iterate your software, you're limited by science, or by like the turn time of the iteration cycle, like you may be able to iterate your software, you know, continuous delivery, you may every day have a new version of the software, but you know, hardware cycles are such that it takes, you know, things have to be produced or made six months, you know, a year, and that can be a challenge. And so I think that observation is, is very astute that's like this difference between a software first company and, you know, also software thing. And so you look to transition from the company doing the sequencing to a software company. And then that sounds like it wasn't it's not your role now, not to spoil it, but it sounds like you're getting closer. Yeah, actually. So first of all, I think you make a great point that I think we do need software engineers in all of the different aspects. And I certainly don't mean
你所暗示的，也许在其中一些公司中，你受到科学的限制，或者受到迭代周期的周转时间的限制，你可能能够迭代你的软件，你受到科学的限制，或者受到迭代周转时间的限制，你可能能够迭代你的软件，你知道，持续交付，你可能每天都有新版本的软件，但你知道，硬件周期是这样的，需要，你知道，事情必须在六个月内生产或制造，你知道，一年，这可能是一个挑战。所以我认为这种观察是非常敏锐的，这就是软件第一公司和软件公司之间的区别。所以你希望从做测序的公司过渡到软件公司。听起来这还不是你现在的角色，不是为了剧透，但听起来你越来越近了。是的，实际上。首先，我认为你提出了一个很好的观点，我认为我们在所有不同的方面确实都需要软件工程师，我当然不是那个意思
to say that one is better than the other. I think for me, so I actually did two companies first that were more focused on sequencing and analyzing the data coming off of the sequencer and delivering, you know, actionable results to patients. And I left that feeling like it was very interesting, but I just wanted to try a pure software company so that I knew what both sides of the coin looked like. And so actually after those two jobs that were focused on, you know, more on bioinformatics work, that's how I ended up at Akasa, where I'm at now. And I joined Akasa when we were maybe five or so full-time employees. And I was one of the very early software engineers. So that was also a really exciting experience to, you know,
说一个比另一个更好。我想对我来说，实际上我先做了两家公司，它们更专注于测序和分析测序仪出来的数据，并向患者提供可行的结果。我离开时觉得这很有趣，但我只想尝试一家纯软件公司，这样我就知道硬币的两面是什么样的。所以实际上在从事生物信息学工作的这两份工作之后，这就是我最终来到现在所在的Akasa的原因。我加入Akasa时，我们大概有五个左右的全职员工。我是早期软件工程师之一。所以这也是一次非常令人兴奋的经历，
join at the beginning and help build the initial versions of the product while we were just trying to get product market fit and then see how much it's grown since then. Oh, wow. So yeah, I think it's always interesting. So like only five people working there. That's pretty tough. Like I guess like that's, you're not one of the people, it doesn't sound like you were the kind of group of people founding the company, which I kind of get that. And then the big company, but that those first few people, did you know some of the people who had founded the company? Or were you just like so convinced by their pits that like you were won over? I did. I knew one of our co-founders, our VP of engineering from my first job. And, you know, that was a big factor in leading me to join the company. Otherwise,
刚开始加入并帮助构建产品的初始版本，当时我们正试图获得产品市场契合度，然后看看从那以后它增长了多少。哦，哇。所以，是的，我认为这总是很有趣。所以只有五个人在那里工作。这挺难的。我想就像那一样，你不是那种人，听起来你不是创立公司的那一群人，我有点明白。然后是大公司，但那最初的几个人，你认识一些创立公司的人吗？还是你只是被他们的推销说服了，以至于你被赢得了？我认识。我从第一份工作就认识我们的联合创始人之一，我们的工程副总裁。而且，你知道，这是一个让我加入公司的重要因素。否则，
you know, it's very hard to get signal on a seed stage startup and know, you know, know if it's going to be successful or not, or know if you're going to enjoy working with the people. Because by definition, at that stage, there's very little product maturity, and you're kind of signing up to take a lot of risks if you join a company at that stage so at least knowing somebody personally who I who I liked and respected was really helpful I guess there's signal and knowing someone that you don't like as well it just might be it might be a different kind of signal exactly yeah oh that's awesome okay so you started early and then I imagine i i actually
你知道，在种子轮初创公司获得信号并知道它是否会成功，或者知道你是否会喜欢和这些人一起工作是非常困难的。因为根据定义，在这个阶段，产品的成熟度很低，如果你在这个阶段加入一家公司，你就是在签约承担很多风险，所以至少认识一个我喜欢和尊重的个人真的很酷。我想认识一个你也不喜欢的人也有信号，它可能只是另一种信号，完全是这样。哦，太棒了。好吧，所以你很早就开始了，然后我想我 실제로
just uh confession time again i've never worked at like a small company i always worked at like very large companies i always think kind of like you're like it's something i i would i kind of in my mind feel one day i want to try and just experience the difference but how was it being at a company trying to kind of get the product out, find the fit, like, you know, probably build sales, all that kind of stuff as a software engineer? Like, what did you find the experience to be like? I found it to be really exciting and also a lot of responsibility, which was what I was looking for. So that was a good thing.
只是，又是坦白时间，我从来没有在小公司工作过，我总是去非常大的公司工作。我总是觉得就像你一样，这是我想有一天尝试并体验差异的事情。但是作为一名软件工程师，在一家试图将产品推向市场、寻找契合点、可能建立销售等各种事情的公司里，感觉怎么样？你觉得这段经历怎么样？我觉得这非常令人兴奋，也有很多责任，这正是我所寻找的。所以这是一件好事。
You know, in the early days, it was really just trying to build the first version of the product, get it in front of customers and get feedback and iterate quickly. I think that was the most important thing was to make sure that we could make changes quickly and speed up that iteration cycle of, you know, getting feedback and putting another rev on the product, getting it in front of customers again. And at the beginning, I think we were really in the sort of do things that don't scale phase, which even if it takes a ton of effort to make one customer happy, it's totally worth it. And we just wanted to prove that we could provide value. And once we did that, repeatedly, you know, two or three times, then we started to think about basically how to replicate this and how to be able to turn it on with less effort. And also, you know, a non-trivial challenge is also how to bring on more people onto the team and, you know, sort of give them a template for how we do our work and how they can, you know, take
你知道，在早期，真的只是试图构建产品的第一个版本，把它放在客户面前并获得反馈，然后快速迭代。我认为最重要的是确保我们能够快速做出改变，并加快获取反馈的迭代周期，并在产品上进行另一次改进，再次将其放在客户面前。起初，我认为我们真的处于做不规模化的事情的阶段，即使让一个客户开心需要付出巨大的努力，这也是完全值得的。我们只是想证明我们能够提供价值。一旦我们这样做了，重复了，你知道，两三次，然后我们开始考虑基本上如何复制这一点以及如何以更少的努力打开它。而且，你知道，一个非同寻常的挑战也是如何让更多的人加入团队，你知道，为我们如何做工作提供一个模板，以及他们如何能够
a customer and go make a new customer happy using the tools that we provided. I think that's another really good observation. I was having a very related conversation with people at work, several people about what you're saying, which is there's a difference between having more work that needs to be done. And like, having stuff set up in a way so that like the work needing to be done can be solved by bringing more people on. And it was like a very wordy, I need to come up with a catchier way of saying it, I guess. But like, this thing about the rotation of, you know, how things are built and done that going from, I have 1000 tasks, but I'm the only person who can do them to I have 1000 tasks, but
带一个客户去使用我们提供的工具让新客户开心。我认为这是另一个非常好的观察。我正在和工作中的人进行一次非常相关的对话，几个人都在讨论你所说的话，那就是还有更多需要做的工作和把事情设置好以便可以通过引入更多人来解决需要做的工作之间存在差异。这就像是一个非常冗长的话题，我想我想出一个更吸引人的说法，我想。但是，就像关于如何构建和完成事物的轮换这件事，从我有1000个任务，但我是唯一能做这些任务的人到我有1000个任务，但是
they're organized in such a way that like, I can effectively communicate to others, like, how that we can, you know, efficiently combine our powers together in a, in a, you know, cooperative way, rather than just stepping on each other's toes or constantly accidentally doing the same work. And so I think that thing you mentioned about thinking about the work in a way that you could hand it and describe it to someone new so they can replicate it is a challenge I don't hear talked about a lot. Yeah, absolutely. Have you read that famous essay called The Mythical Man Month? Have you heard of that? I do know about it. I do know what the theory says, but I haven't actually read it.
它们的组织方式使得我能够有效地与他人沟通，我们如何才能以合作的方式有效地结合我们的力量，而不是互相踩脚趾或不小心做同样的工作。所以我认为你提到的关于以你可以将其交给新员工并向他们描述以便他们可以复制的方式思考工作的这件事，是我不常听到的挑战。是的，绝对的。你读过那本著名的散文《人月神话》吗？你听说过吗？我知道。我知道这个理论说的是什么，但我没有真正读过。
I guess this will be my conviction to have to go read it after this. Yeah, it's a good read. And it's pretty short. And I often recommend that people on my team or new people who join the company read it because I think it talks about exactly this problem where, you know, you have a team of two or three people, and they're doing really well. And then you want to make them be able to do more. So the first instinct is, you know, what happens if we double the team, we should expect twice the output, right? But that turns out not to be right due to
我想这将是我读完这本书后的信念。是的，这是一本好书。而且它相当短。我经常建议我团队里的人或加入公司的新人去读它，因为我认为它讨论的正是这个问题，你知道，你有一个两三个人的团队，他们做得很好。然后你想让他们做得更多。所以第一直觉是，你知道，如果我们把团队翻倍会发生什么，我们应该期望产出翻倍，对吧？但事实证明这是不对的，因为
onboarding and communication overhead and people not knowing exactly what their responsibilities are. And yeah, I think that that's a big part of technical leadership actually is figuring out how to set up projects in a way that you can effectively bring new people onto the project and make sure that they're productive and they have enough runway. And you want to avoid that N squared communication problem where everybody has to talk with everybody else in order to figure out what their integration points are. Ideally, you want to make sure that people know exactly what they're building and someone has sort of planned it up front. So it's all going to fit together if everyone builds it correctly. All right. I have it. I wrote it down. I'm adding it. I feel called out. It's a classic. I know it's been recommended and I've been lazy. So to the topic though, you were mentioning doing a lot of things that don't scale and just getting it done. And not necessarily, I don't want to say
入职和沟通开销以及人们不清楚他们的责任是什么。是的，我认为这其实是技术领导力的很大一部分，就是弄清楚如何以能够有效地将新员工带入项目并确保他们具有生产力且有足够跑道的方式来设置项目。你希望避免N平方的沟通问题，即每个人都必须与其他人交谈以弄清楚他们的集成点是什么。理想情况下，你想要确保人们确切地知道他们在构建什么，并且有人已经预先计划好了。所以如果每个人都正确构建，这一切都会组合在一起。好的。我有。我把它写下来了。我要加上。我感觉被点名了。这是一本经典。我知道有人推荐过它，而我很懒。不过回到这个话题，你提到做了很多不能规模化的事情，并把它做完了。不一定，我不想说
getting it done right is a second thing, but just getting it done. And not necessarily, I don't want to say getting it done right is a second thing, but just getting it done in a way that gets it out, gets the feedback, gets the cycle started, you know, getting iterations and these kinds of things. I got to imagine like at that time, a lot of the work is you might step in and do it yourself rather than, you know, trying to write the software that you know you should write to do it. Is that kind of well describing of what was happening at the time? Yeah, that's right. You know, initially, when you're just trying to test the value of something, you want a
把事情做好是第二件事，但只要把它做好就行了。不一定，我不想说把事情做好是第二件事，只要以一种让它发布、获得反馈、开始循环、你知道，获得迭代和这些种类的事情的方式把它做好就行了。我得想象，在那个时候，很多工作可能是你可能会亲自介入并去做，而不是试图编写你知道应该编写来完成它的软件。这能很好地描述当时发生的事情吗？是的，没错。最初，当你只是试图测试某东西的价值时，你想要一个
cheap prototype before you invest a ton of effort in automating it. So sometimes it would be, you know, testing something manually and just, just seeing if it would even work if we, if we built a computer program to automate it. Or, you know, sometimes, you know, before we invested in fully automatic CICD and, you know, deployments running all around the clock. You know, it would just be, what if I run this once a day manually and see how much work it picks up and see if it can do the job for our customers. And then, you know, once we get past that phase where it's clear that the solution is providing value, then it makes sense to really invest in it as a fully automated solution. I think that is a, I don't want to say, I think when we have software only companies, sometimes that bit of difference in big companies,
廉价的原型，然后再投入大量精力进行自动化。所以有时它会是，你知道，手动测试某东西，只是看看如果我们构建一个计算机程序来自动化它，它是否还能工作。或者，你知道，有时，在我们投资于完全自动化的CICD和全天候运行的部署之前。你知道，它只会是，如果我每天手动运行一次这个，看看它接收了多少工作，看看它是否能为我们的客户完成工作。然后，你知道，一旦我们度过了那个阶段，很明显该解决方案正在提供价值，那么真正将其投资为完全自动化的解决方案就很有意义了。我认为这是一个，我不想说，我认为当我们只有软件公司时，有时大公司中那种差异，
at least I've seen gets missed, which is people just go straight to the glamorous solution that sounds really awesome, right? And so you end up building this big infrastructure that has a lot of latency from when you go to start to when it's ready to be done. And then you deliver it and then it gets used once or twice. And it's bit rots and you know, all these problems and then it just the payout wasn't worth the investment. And so I think that this way you describe it of sometimes just biting the bullet and kind of getting it out making sure that it gets used once or twice is is really annoying. You have to do
至少我看到的被错过了，那就是人们直接走向听起来真的很棒的迷人解决方案，对吧？所以你最终构建了这个庞大的基础设施，从你开始到准备完成之间有很多延迟。然后你交付它，然后它被使用了一次或两次。它腐烂了，你知道，所有这些问题，然后回报不值得投资。所以我认为你描述的这种有时只是咬紧牙关并把它拿出来确保它被使用一次或两次的方式真的很烦人。你必须做
this thing once a day. But yeah, I think that's such a great way to get a minimally viable product out, get feedback on it, and not on the whole product, but even on just like little bits of functionality. Yeah, absolutely. And especially at a startup, inherently, you have limited resources, and there's a lot of opportunity cost. As a startup, you're trying to prove
这个事情一天一次。但是，是的，我认为这是推出最小可行产品、获取关于它的反馈的绝佳方式，不仅针对整个产品，甚至只针对一小部分功能。是的，绝对的。特别是对于一家初创公司，本质上，你的资源有限，而且有很多机会成本。作为一家初创公司，你正在努力证明
yourself and you're trying to make money and do it with a small team. And so if you spend three months or six months building some glamorous solution and it turns out that customers don't like it, then you're actually just wasted really valuable resources and more importantly, wasted time and wasted some of your social capital with that customer as well. So you guys are working at the startup in the, we haven't really said, but like in the healthcare space and you're talking about customers, what is kind of the flow of stuff you guys are working on looks like? Like what is it that you're trying to do to get out in front of people? Yeah, absolutely. So basically, ACASA's goal here is to help hospitals that end up having a ton of manual human repetitive work, you know, often centered around working with health insurance
你自己尝试去赚钱并组建一个小团队。因此，如果你花三到六个月的时间去构建一个光鲜亮丽的解决方案，结果客户并不喜欢，那么你实际上只是浪费了非常宝贵的资源，更重要的是，浪费了时间，并且也浪费了你在该客户那里的部分社会资本。所以你们在一家创业公司工作，我们之前没有明确说明，但就是在医疗健康领域，当你们谈到客户时，你们正在做的事情的流程是什么样的？你们试图在人们面前展现什么？是的，完全正确。所以基本上，ACASA的目标是帮助那些最终有大量人工、重复性工作的医院，你知道，这些工作通常围绕着与健康保险公司合作展开。
companies. And, you know, the health healthcare industry is super complex. So hospitals have hundreds or thousands of workflows that they're running, and they basically have humans serving all of these every day. So our goal is to build an end-to-end automation. So learn what a human does at a hospital system, figure out all the manual and repetitive tasks that they're doing, and then build a computer program that can completely automate it end to end. And so, you know, we often start by carving out specific pieces of what we call the revenue cycle management or medical billing. So for example, carving out a product where humans are paid to check the status of a claim that the hospital submitted to the insurance
而且，你知道，医疗健康行业超级复杂。因此，医院有数百或数千个他们正在运行的工作流程，他们基本上每天都让人工来处理所有这些工作。所以我们的目标是构建端到端的自动化。也就是了解人类在医院系统中所做的事情，弄清楚他们正在做的所有手动和重复性任务，然后构建一个可以完全实现端到端自动化的计算机程序。因此，你知道，我们通常首先从剥离我们称之为收入周期管理或医疗账单的特定部分开始。例如，剥离出一个产品，让人们获得报酬去检查医院一个月或两个月前提交给保险公司的理赔申请的状态，
company a month or two ago, but didn't get paid for. Or humans are paid to look at every denied claim that comes through and decide if it can be fixed and resubmitted to the hospital or to the insurance company and have that revenue recouped. And so basically, Akasa's idea here is, you know, effectively enterprise software company, helping hospitals automate a lot of the manual work that they have to do today. I think like, I want to come back, I want to come back to Akasa here in a minute. But but to kind of like, I see now, okay, so you guys are looking to automate these processes.
但当时没有拿到钱。或者人们获得报酬去查看收到的每一个被拒绝的理赔申请，并决定是否可以修复它并重新提交给医院或保险公司，从而追回这笔收入。因此基本上，Akasa这里的想法是，你知道，实际上是一家企业软件公司，帮助医院自动化他们今天必须做的许多手工工作。我想，我想稍后再回到Akasa这个话题。但是，为了，我现在的理解是，好吧，所以你们正打算把这些流程自动化。
I think this sounds like not even all that specific to healthcare. There are things even just in software engineering day-to-day that I do by hand and think about automating. So you guys are kind of taking, trying to understand which of those matter, how do you do them? And you're sort of going through and finding, there's this sort of, not to spoil, but there's sort of a big pipeline of stuff that flows from, you know, sort of inputs to something at the end. Maybe there's cycles in it, maybe there's not.
我觉得这听起来甚至没有那么强的医疗健康特异性。有些事情甚至只是在我日常的软件工程中，我也会亲自动手去做并考虑将其自动化。所以你们正在尝试理解其中哪些是重要的，你们是怎么做到的？你们正在经历并发现，这里有一种，不是要剧透，但这里有一个巨大的管线，流程从输入端一直流向最终的东西。也许其中有循环，也许没有。
Hint, we're teeing up some future discussion here. But at the beginning, there are all these things where there are effectively humans or manual processes sort of getting the ball rolling. And so you're starting by figuring out where those are and trying to automate them. Yeah, that's exactly right. And you're actually alluding to something really good, which is everything we've built in our platform is completely generic. So we've been pretty intentional about this as a company. And we sort of structure the company in terms of the platform arm and then the integrations arm. And on the platform side, everything we've built is totally generic. And you could really use it to automate almost any task that you can do on a computer. We've started
提示：我们正在为将来的讨论做铺垫。但在开始时，所有这些事情实际上都是由人类或人工流程来推动的。所以你们从找出这些流程所在的位置开始，并试图将它们自动化。是的，完全正确。你实际上暗示了一个非常好的点，那就是我们在平台上构建的一切都是完全通用的。所以作为一家公司，我们在这一点上一直相当刻意。我们把公司结构化为平台部门和集成部门。在平台端，我们构建的一切都是完全通用的。你真的可以用它来自动化你在计算机上能做的几乎任何任务。我们从
out by focusing in revenue cycle management, or again, medical billing, because it turns out that there's just a ton of manual repetitive work that happens in that industry. But in the future, we could totally take our platform and, you know, go help customers and almost any industry that has a lot of manual work, because we've built our platform in a generic way. So I guess in thinking about, in the generic sense, I guess, thinking about this task automation and doing these things, I guess one place where I see humans step in is when you're going between two systems
专注于收入周期管理（或者说医疗账单）开始，因为事实证明，该行业中存在大量的手动重复性工作。但未来，我们可以完全拿着我们的平台，去帮助几乎任何拥有大量手动工作的行业的客户，因为我们以通用方式构建了平台。所以我想在从通用意义上思考时，思考这种任务自动化并做这些事情，我想我看到人类介入的一个地方是当你在两个系统之间进行交互时
that don't have a good way of communicating. And then the other thing I'll think about, but I don't know that we'll talk too much about that is like sort of sensory related like oh i want i need the thing to count the number of humans that come in this door or whatever where you might need to solve a sort of bigger problem that i don't know is as generic you know or you're trying to sense something in the real world where you might ask a human to do it trivially and then put it into the computer but i think this i i don't know if kind of which you sort of fall on, but I've seen both cases. But this case, even just from one system,
这些系统没有很好的沟通方式。然后另一件我想到的事，但我不知道我们会谈论太多，就是那种与感官相关的事，比如，哦，我想要，我需要那个东西来计算进这扇门的人数，或者诸如此类的事，你可能需要解决一个我不知道是否具有通用性的更大问题，你知道的，或者你试图感知现实世界中的某些东西，你可能会要求人类轻而易举地做到这一点，然后把它输入计算机，但我认为这个，我不知道你偏向哪一种，但我两种情况都见过。但这种情况，甚至只是从一个系统到另一个系统，
I have something in an Excel sheet and I need it in a SQL database. And it's like, yeah, I probably could find a tool to do that, but I could also just like, you know, write it myself. Yeah, exactly. And I think we focus more on that former end. So it's a couple of things. One is coordination between systems, like you mentioned. So healthcare software is complex. The insurance companies are running their own software systems. Hospitals are running their own electronic health record systems. And one of the big problems is effectively synchronization
我有一份Excel表格里的数据，我需要把它放到SQL数据库里。这就好比，是的，我大概能找到一个工具来做这件事，但我也可以自己写代码来搞定。是的，完全正确。而且我认为我们更多地关注前半部分。所以主要有几件事。一个是系统之间的协调，就像你提到的。因此，医疗软件很复杂。保险公司在运行他们自己的软件系统。医院在运行他们自己的电子健康记录系统。而其中一个大问题实际上就是所有这些系统之间的同步。
between all these systems. So, you know, hospital submits a claim and they wait a month or two and they don't hear back from the insurance company. So they're effectively paying someone to go into the hospital system, which we call the electronic health record, grab all the information about that claim, open up a web browser, go to the health insurance company's website, type in the information about this claim, click, you know, where's my claim, get a web page back, read that web page to understand the status of the claim, and then go back to the electronic health record system and update the status of the claim accordingly. And so this is an example of a very simple revenue cycle workflow. And we can basically automate all parts
所以，你知道，医院提交了一个理赔申请，然后等待一个月或两个月，却没有收到保险公司的回复。所以他们实际上是在付钱让人进入医院系统（我们称之为电子健康记录），抓取关于该理赔的所有信息，打开网络浏览器，访问健康保险公司的网站，输入关于这个理赔的信息，点击‘我的理赔在哪里’，得到一个网页，阅读该网页以了解理赔的状态，然后返回电子健康记录系统并相应地更新理赔的状态。所以这是一个非常简单的收入周期工作流程的例子。而我们基本上可以自动化所有这些部分
of it end to end. So not only the synchronization between systems, but we can also automate the specific data entry and data scraping within a system. So for example, within the electronic health record application, which typically don't support good APIs, we can, you know, build robots to effectively automate, you know, the scraping and the data entry that a human would normally have to do. Awesome. So like hearing this, my brain is already sort of like we're in and we kind of, I think a bit tried to tee this up in the in the intro, even for this pattern here, where if all of these things were already available in a single program running for a very limited time span, you would just write it in, you know, Python or C++ or whatever, right? Read from the
端到端地完成这一切。因此，不仅是系统之间的同步，我们还可以自动化系统内的特定数据录入和数据抓取。例如，在电子健康记录应用程序中，它们通常不支持良好的API，我们可以编写机器人来有效地自动化人类通常必须进行的网页抓取和数据录入。太棒了。听到这里，我的大脑已经在思考了，我们前面在引言里也尝试为这个模式做过铺垫——如果所有这些事情本来就可以在一个运行时间非常有限的单一程序中完成，你大概就会直接用Python、C++或者其他什么语言来写它，对吧？从数据库
database, write to the database, you know, wait for the human input, do this thing. And if we're running over just a short time span where everything was available, very, very clean APIs or whatever, you might just say, you know, I'm going to do this in a piece of software. But this recurring problem that you're sort of describing occurring here or starting to allude to, maybe I'm jumping ahead, but starting to allude to here is that, you know, you need to have a program itself to do a very complex, latency-heavy job of like pulling this system once a week or once a day, you know, reading some data out via some, you know, headless web server that you have to,
读取数据，写入数据库，等待人类输入，完成某项任务。如果我们只是在一个很短的时间范围内运行，所有东西都触手可得，API非常非常干净，你可能就会说，我用一段软件来搞定这事就行了。但你在这里描述的、或者开始暗示的这个反复出现的问题——也许我有点操之过急了——开始暗示的是，你需要一个程序本身来做一件非常复杂、延迟很高的工作，比如每周或每天轮询一次这个系统，通过某种你必须用到的无头网页服务器读取一些数据，
you do this very complicated thing where it's not a clean single program, but in fact, you actually need to coordinate a set of programs and tasks. You need to run some repeatedly. There's decisions. You need this almost kind of meta program that needs to be described and coordinated. And so this is something that's not unique to what you're saying. But anything where you have this, it could be batch jobs that just take a long time because they process terabytes of information. And so, you know, basically what we're doing here is
你做了一件非常复杂的事情，它不是一个干净的单一程序，事实上，你实际上需要协调一组程序和任务。有些你需要重复运行。这里面有决策。你几乎需要这种可以被描述和协调的元程序。所以这并非你独有的情况。任何存在这种需求的地方，都可能是那些因为处理数TB信息而需要很长时间的批处理任务，所以，基本上我们在这里做的是
you can think about Akasa automations as we can build an API around any action that you can do on a computer. So let's say you need to scrape a desktop application. And, you know, under the hood, we're going to use computer vision to, you know, train a CV model to understand what's happening on the screen. And that model is going to be running and telling us where to click and where to type and helping us read the data on the screen. the ways that they're often served in healthcare, you basically only have pixels. You don't have any structured information about what's on the page. And so we have to sort of impose that or determine that ourselves. But all of that is abstracted behind our API call. So you can effectively call
你可以把Akasa的自动化看作：我们可以围绕你在计算机上能做的任何操作构建一个API。比方说，你需要抓取一个桌面应用程序。在底层，我们会使用计算机视觉，训练一个CV模型来理解屏幕上发生的事情，这个模型将会运行并告诉我们在哪里点击、在哪里输入，并帮助我们读取屏幕上的数据。在医疗保健领域，它们通常只提供像素级别的呈现。你没有任何关于页面内容的结构化信息。因此，我们必须自己去强加或确定这种结构。但所有这些都在我们的API调用背后被抽象化了。所以你实际上可以调用
an API that says, you know, go get me the information about this claim. Or similar to what you were alluding to, you can call an API that says, you know, run a headless web browser and go check the status of this claim at the insurance company. And you can imagine as the company has grown, when we've taken on all different sorts of workflows, and, you know, we're live with hospitals all over the country, that the number of these API endpoints that we have internally has grown tremendously. And then the question becomes, how do we make it so that we can tie
一个API，说“去帮我获取这个理赔的信息”。或者类似于你之前暗示的，你可以调用一个API，说“运行一个无头网页浏览器，去保险公司检查这个理赔的状态”。你可以想象，随着公司的发展，当我们承接了各种不同类型的工作流，并且我们的业务已经遍布全国各地的医院时，我们在内部拥有的这些API端点的数量已经呈爆炸式增长。那么问题就变成了，我们如何做到这一点：我们可以把
any of these building blocks together in any order that we want to build an automation for a customer? And then how do we get all of the nice stuff like results management and error tracking and asynchronous execution and things like that? Okay. Yeah. I was just about to say, but you already kind of started alluding to it. In my head, I'm trying to kind of think about, in the case that I had it, like when there's always this timing we mentioned going from, you know,
任何这些构建块以我们想要的任何顺序组合在一起，为客户构建自动化？然后，我们如何获得所有那些好用的功能，比如结果管理、错误跟踪、异步执行等等？好的。是的，我正要说，但你已经开始暗示这一点了。在我的脑海里，我试图去思考我所经历的情况，正如我们所提到的，从人类构建原型到自动化，总是存在这种时间上的权衡，你试图去衡量和监控：这种跳跃是否值得？在这里，我试图思考的是，到底是什么样的因素会促使你去寻找工作流引擎这种技术和解决方案来帮助你解决这些问题？
human building a prototype to like automating and you try to measure something and monitor, like, is it worth that jump? And here I'm trying to think like, what are the kinds of things which would make you reach for the technology, the solution of a workflow engine and sort of helping you with these things?
我刚开始时提到了延迟或者运行的时长，工作流引擎可以帮到你。但接着你提到了结果管理，我很想听听那是什么意思。你还提到了异步处理。所以我开始联想到并行处理。不过，我想到的另一个因素是重试。你刚才提到的很多事情，
And I sort of alluded in the beginning about like latency or like the length of running. workflow engine and sort of helping you with these things. And I sort of alluded in the beginning about like latency or like the length of running. But then you sort of said this like results management. I'm interested to hear a bit what that is. You also said like this asynchronous stuff. So I start to think like, you know, parallel. But also one that I was thinking about too is like retrying. So a lot of these things you're saying you do it
由于超出你控制范围的原因，可能偶尔就是无法正常工作，或者网站崩溃了，诸如此类。因此，尝试几次，如果这个任务已经很久没有运行了，就可能会向你发出警报——这会成为我脑海中的另一个信号，提示我可能不应该只写一个凑合的脚本。绝对的。你完全正确。你知道，这些都是我们内置到工作流引擎中的功能。我们是如何注意到这一点的呢？我们发现在公司的集成部门，人们非常喜欢我们公开的API端点。但是
for reasons outside of your control, probably occasionally just don't work or the website is down or, you know, whatever. And so trying it a few times, then maybe alerting you, you know, if like, hey, this job hasn't been running in so long, there'll be another thing in my head that I think would sort of cue me up that like, I probably should reach for more than just like a hacky script. Absolutely. You're exactly right. And you know, these are all things we've, we've built into our workflow engine. And I think how we noticed it was, we noticed that on the integration arm of the company, people really liked, you know, effectively the API end points that we were exposing. But, But we saw more and more of the work on that end going towards, you know, making sure that the bot retries if it fails, because,
我们看到该领域越来越多的工作转向了确保机器人在失败时能够重试，因为可能客户的VPN系统崩溃了，或者确保它只重试几次，然后我们就会收到警报，并确保我们拥有日志记录和跟踪功能，我们可以看到哪些API端点成功了，哪些失败了，并且对这些类型的问题有很好的可见性。正是在那个时候，我们开始考虑，也许在平台端，我们不仅暴露这些API端点，还暴露一个框架，基本上能够随心所欲地将它们串联起来，并在过程中免费获得大量功能。所以，我的意思是，我也听说过在
you know, maybe the customer's VPN system went down, or, you know, making sure that it only retries a few times, and then we get an alert and making sure that we had logging and tracking, and we can see which API endpoints were succeeding, which ones were failing, and that we had good visibility into those types of issues. That's when we thought about maybe on the platform side, we don't just expose these API endpoints, but we also expose a framework for basically being able to tie them together however you want and get a lot of functionality for free in the process. So I mean, I also, I guess I have heard the in the
同一领域中——我不知道我们能否试着给它下一个定义，或者你是否清楚——我听过类似的描述，将其称为ETL框架，也就是提取、转换、加载（Extract, Transform, Load）。我认为工作流引擎，在你的心目中，这两种术语之间有区别吗？其中一个是伞形术语，而工作流引擎类似于……
same space, and maybe I don't know if we can try to come up with a definition or if you if you sort of know, but I think I've heard the same same kind of description described as like ETL frameworks is sort of extract, transform, load. And I think workflow engines, like do you is there kind of description described as like ETL frameworks, this sort of extract, transform, load. And I think workflow engines, is there kind of in your mind, like a difference between these two? Is one like just an umbrella term and workflow engines are kind of like,
你如何看待这些不同的术语？是的，这是一个好问题。我肯定算不上行业中各种解决方案的专家。好吧，这倒也是。但我想你会看到很多工作流引擎，或者你会看到人们把像Airflow这样的工具称为工作流引擎，然后经常将其用于ETL流程。所以我想这些解决方案通常是密不可分的，ETL只是你可以用工作流引擎解决的一种业务问题。我确实看到过一些区别，比如你
how do you kind of think about those different terms? Yeah, it's a good question. I'm certainly, I would say not an expert in all of the different solutions in the industry. Yeah, fair enough. But I think you'll see a lot of workflow engines, you know, or you'll see people call something like Airflow a workflow engine and then often use it for ETL processes. And so I think often these solutions go hand in hand and ETLs are sort of one type of business problem that you can solve with a workflow engine. I have seen sort of a distinction between, you know, engines that you
用来移动数据的引擎（如执行ETL等任务），与更偏向微服务编排的框架之间存在差异。也就是说，你用来协调一堆不同API或一堆不同服务之间的调用，确保它们按正确顺序运行，并将一个调用的输出传递给另一个调用的输入的这类框架。
use to move data around, like doing things such as ETL, and then more of the almost microservice orchestration frameworks. So frameworks that you use to coordinate calls between a bunch of different APIs or a bunch of different services and make sure that they run in the right order and the inputs of one get, or the output of one call gets passed into the input of the other and that type of stuff.
所以，如果非要对我见过的工具进行分类，它们大概可以归为这两类：一类是ETL或数据管理流程，另一类是更偏向业务流程管理的框架——即编排一堆API调用或微服务以实现最终结果。好的。是的，我也不是专家，所以我接受你的说法。我买账。我想还有几个有趣的事情。你提到一家初创公司在权衡机会成本。你们提到我们在工作流引擎的描述以及你们的应用方式之间摇摆不定。但我认为作为一个案例研究，它甚至更有趣，那就是你们开始做这些任务，比如抓取，这些感觉非常定制化。
And so if I had to try to, you know, bifurcate the tools that I've seen, they probably fall into these two categories of, you know, ETL or data management processes, and then more business process management. So orchestrating a bunch of API calls or microservices to kind of achieve a final outcome. Okay. Yeah. I'm also not an expert, so I'll buy it. I'll buy what you're selling. And so I guess a couple other interesting things. So you mentioned a startup trying to think about the opportunity costs. You guys are saying that we're sort of fluctuating between the description of workflow engines and how you guys applied it. But I think it's interesting as a case study, if not more, which is you guys are starting to do these tasks, these scraping, and these are like things that feel pretty custom.
也许你用了一些现有的东西，但它们非常针对每个程序、每个网站。每个网站都不同。精通这一点是一项技能。但随后这些集成、这些工作流、这些——正如你提到的，还有其他人在做这些事情。我听说过的一个是Apache的Airflow，或者还有Argo之类的东西。是什么让你决定——好吧，抛开你们自己构建的具体原因不谈，甚至就普遍情况而言——你们是如何处理这种权衡的：是去选择
Maybe you're using some existing stuff, but very specific to each program, to each website. Everybody's different. And getting good at that is a skill. But then these integrations these workflows these you know like you mentioned there are other people doing them you know the things so i hear about i think like the apache one is airflow or there's like argo like there's a what makes you decide that hey we we think that there's a i guess the specifics of why you built your own but even just in general like how did you guys approach this trade-off of reaching for
一个现成的、可能并非百分之百契合但比从头开始要好得多的现有工具？是的，完全如此。我认为这种“购买与自研”的张力在许多初创公司中都存在。在初创公司，你的资源有限，你不想为你必须使用的每一款软件重复发明轮子。我喜欢举的一个例子是，大多数初创公司大概都不应该去发明自己的CI/CD系统，除非这就是他们提供的产品。原因在于，CI/CD系统可能不够完美，或者可能无法完全实现你想要的功能，但它们作为现成产品已经足够好
an existing one that maybe is not an exact fit but it's a lot closer of a starting point than sort of like starting from scratch? Yeah, absolutely. I think this tension of buy versus build is present in a lot of startups where, you know, at a startup you have limited resources and you don't want to reinvent the wheel for every piece of software that you have to use. And so an example I like to use is most startups probably should not be inventing their own CICD system unless that's the product that they're offering. And the reason is that CICD systems maybe aren't perfect or maybe don't do exactly what you want, but are good enough off the shelf
能够让你们的团队保持高速运转。把宝贵的资源花在构建诸如新的CI/CD框架之类的事情上，会分散你投入到自己公司核心业务上的精力。因此，在Akasa，我们实际上寻找过现有的工作流引擎，并对该领域的许多解决方案进行了相当详细的审计。最终我们选择自研，原因有几个。第一个原因是，许多
to enable your teams to keep moving fast. And spending your valuable resources, building something like a new CICD framework, takes away from the investment that you can put in to your own company. And so at Acasa, we actually looked for existing workflow engines and did a pretty detailed audit of a lot of solutions that were in the space. And we ended up building our own for a few reasons. The first reason was that a lot of
工作流引擎都围绕着构建DAG（有向无环图）的概念展开。这基本上就是一个没有循环的图。你的工作是构建DAG，而引擎的工作是极其高效地执行这个DAG。但在Akasa的业务领域中，我们发现许多自动化流程都太动态了，无法纳入DAG这个概念中。我们需要询问一家保险公司，他们告诉我们，他们并不是承保该患者的机构，
workflow engines are focused around this idea of constructing a DAG, which is a directed acyclic graph. So basically a graph with no loops in it. And then your job is to construct the DAG, and then the engine's job is to execute that DAG very efficiently. But in Akasa's domain, what we found is that a lot of automations are too dynamic to fit into this concept of a DAG. And, you know, we have to ask one insurance company, and they tell us that, you know, they are not the ones that insure this patient,
但他们知道谁可能是，并向我们提供了一些更多信息。然后我们据此调整搜索图。所以，也许我先停在这里。我们决定自研的原因有几个，这是第一个，我想先看看这是否说得通。是的，我认为这种“没有循环”、与其说是决策树，不如说是从左到右的推进（可能伴有一些重试）的特点，是一个相当大的区别。在讨论仅仅拥有各个阶段（可能还会进行分支和汇聚——我不知道这词准不准，但就是分支然后重新汇聚）的流程时，这可能很复杂。你可能会选择工作流引擎，但这种动态性，
but they know who might be and they give us some more information. And then we adjust the search graph from there. So maybe I'll pause there. There were sort of several reasons that we decided to build our own, but that was the first and I wanted to see if that makes sense. Yeah, I think this, like, no cycle, not really a decision tree, but just this march from left to right with maybe some retries is a pretty big distinction, a pretty big upfront thing to talk about the difference between sort of just having the stages and maybe they fan out and fan in is that I don't know if that's the right words, but like sort of branch out and then, you know, come back together, can be complex. And you may reach for workflow image, but this like dynamicism that like, you
比如有条件判断，而且更加复杂。我想，我甚至已经在用“从左到右”来形容了，因为许多这类工具都带有可视化功能，你可以去思考——虽然术语可能不同，但包括各个阶段和分支的可视化，因为所有这些工作流的复杂度可能会变得非常高。所以，即使你不允许使用那种所见即所得的（What You See Is What You Get）图形界面来编辑工作流，至少通过可视化让人们能够审计或跟踪进度，也是另一个重要的组成部分，我想顺便提一下。不过，是的，这是一个非常棒的观点，在考虑这些问题以及它是否对你的核心业务至关重要时，这不仅是因为你不喜欢其他工具，更是因为如果你选择自研，它确实能推动公司产出的增长。
know, hey, you're it's there's conditionals. And there's, you know, this is more elaborate. I think, oh, I'm also even already talking about it talking like left to right, I guess, like a lot of these come with visualization, you kind of think about i guess terms can different but sort of stages and then in branches and sort of visually because the complexity can grow pretty large for all these workflows and so even if you don't allow sort of what is that whizzy wig what you see is what you even don't allow like a gui for editing the workflows at least like visualizing so people can sort of audit or track the progress is another component just to kind of throw that out there. But yeah, that's a great, great point when sort of thinking about these and whether it's something critical to what you like. Is it just that you don't love the other ones or is it something that if you go build, this is actually going to move the needle for the output of your company. Yeah, exactly. And that kind of leads into the second point, which is basically the output of
是的，完全正确。这自然就引出了第二点，也就是基本上我们公司的产出取决于：我们能以多快的速度为新医院构建自动化？你在许多工作流引擎工具中还会发现另一个现象，那就是编写代码会有点繁琐。它不一定有多难，但有时你必须用YAML编写图，或者你会得到一个语法受限的Python版本，而你只能受限于这些规则。正如我所说，Akasa的自动化是非常动态的。我认为Akasa在根本上也不同于行业中的许多大公司，比如Airbnb、Pinterest这类正在构建大量工作流引擎的公司，因为美国每一家医院的工作流都是不同的。即使是针对完全相同的产出，比如理赔状态、资格验证或拒绝管理，美国每一家医院的做法也各不相同。实际上有句俗话叫
our company is how quickly can we go build automations for new hospitals? And another thing you'll see in a lot of workflow engine tools is it's a little bit annoying to write the code. You know, it's not necessarily hard, but sometimes you have to write the graph in YAML or you get some limited version of Python that has, you know, limited syntax. And that's what you're restricted to using. And as I said, Acasa automations are very dynamic. And I think Acasa is also sort of fundamentally different from a lot of the, you know, big companies in the industry, you know, Airbnb, Pinterest, those types of companies that are building a lot of these workflow engines in that every single hospital in America has different workflows. Even for the same exact product, you know, claim status or eligibility or denials management, every hospital in America does it differently. There's actually a saying in
。
healthcare that if you've seen, you know, one hospital system, you've seen one hospital system. Like, you know, basically, a lot of these workflows really don't generalize. And what that means is that in the limit, a CASA might have to build thousands of workflows that each run at, I would say, small to medium scale, because, you know, data size in healthcare is a lot smaller than what you'll see in the telecom industry or other industries. And that leads to sort of different trade-offs for us, where we would rather make the code really easy to write and basically give people, you know, the full expressiveness of Python, let them write conditionals and loops and, you know, have it be pretty transparent about how that's going to be executed on the backend.
医疗保健就是这样，如果你见过一个医院系统，那就等于你只见过一个医院系统。基本上，很多这样的工作流真的无法通用。这意味着，极端情况下，Akasa可能不得不构建数千个工作流，每个工作流都在我所说的小到中等规模下运行，因为医疗保健中的数据规模比你在电信行业或其他行业中看到的要小得多。这导致我们做出一些不同的权衡，我们更愿意让代码非常容易编写，基本上赋予人们Python的全部表达能力，让他们编写条件语句和循环，并且让后台将如何执行这些代码变得相当透明。
We would rather do that than make the code harder to write and squeeze out a few extra milliseconds on the execution time. I see. I guess like another decision point there that you're describing is like, and even I think also has applicability more broadly. I feel like i keep repeating myself
我们宁愿这样做，也不愿让代码更难编写却只在执行时间上挤出几毫秒的优势。我明白。我想那里描述的另一个决策点是，甚至我认为这也具有更广泛的适用性。我觉得我一直在重复自己
but is uh this thing about when you're building these steps and modules and you know allowing people to kind of piece them together is the consumer of those things like other engineers in your company people on your team only like you're just building this up to make your team go faster or is it even people at an outside company? And sort of how are you like, to what end are you building like the integrations and the flow and these these things? That's a great question. So right now, the consumers of everything my my group builds is other engineers in the company. So you know, I mentioned we have a, you know, platform arm of the company and we're building the workflow engine and we're building, you know, this API framework to be able to wrap any tasks that you can do on a GUI and make an API endpoint
但这就是关于你在构建这些步骤和模块时，允许人们将它们拼凑在一起，这些东西的使用者是谁？是你公司里的其他工程师、你团队里的人吗？你构建这些只是为了让你的团队行动更快，还是也包括外部公司的人？你构建集成、流程和这些东西的最终目的是什么？这是一个很好的问题。所以现在，我所在团队构建的所有东西的使用者都是公司内部的其他工程师。所以你知道的，我提到过我们公司有一个平台部门，我们正在构建工作流引擎，我们正在构建这个API框架，以便能够包装你在图形界面上可以做的任何任务，并制作一个API端点
around it. And then we have engineers at the company who are working directly with customers and helping build an integration for a specific hospital. So right now our user is internal, though the way we've built the tooling is we're hoping that, you know, it's easy enough for someone outside of the company to use as well. And so that's certainly something we hope to do in the future. Maybe it's not an interesting decision there, which is fine. But how do you guys think about this difference between sort of, okay, you have the platform arm, you're building the stuff, you have an internal more like getting under contract. I guess this gets into inside baseball, but like contracting to do the work itself right and so when i look across we talked about software first companies i think there are software first companies which like largely just deliver you an end product and there
围绕它。然后我们公司有工程师直接与客户合作，帮助为特定医院构建集成。所以目前我们的用户是内部的，尽管我们构建工具的方式是希望公司外部的人也能足够容易地使用它。这当然是我们希望在未来做的事情。也许那里没有一个有趣的决定，这也无所谓。但你们如何看待这种差异，就是说，好吧，你们有平台部门，你们在构建这些东西，你们内部有一个更像是签约的部门。我想这有点像行话，但就像签约来做这项工作本身对吧，所以当我审视我们讨论过的软件优先公司时，我认为有些软件优先公司主要只是向你交付最终产品，还有
are other ones which deliver you like the pieces of the lego and you can build anything you want with the legos and you can also pay them to like you know build you your lego castle your lego whatever and i'm just curious like as like startup, like how did you guys approach that thinking about whether you wanted to have that contracting arm? I don't know what to call it, the arm that would like do these things themselves or whether like to try to convince another company to do that or individual hospitals? It's a super interesting question. And I'll talk about it, I think, to the extent that I'm able or allowed to. Oh, yes, please don't do anything. Pardon that.
另一些公司向你交付积木的各个部件，你可以用这些积木构建任何你想要的东西，你也可以付钱让他们为你建造乐高城堡、乐高或其他什么东西，我很好奇，作为一个初创公司，你们是如何看待是否想要拥有这个外包或服务部门的？我不知道该怎么称呼它，那个会自己做这些事情的部门，还是说试图说服另一家公司或个别医院来做？这是一个超级有趣的问题。我想在我能够或被允许的范围内，我会谈谈这个问题。哦，是的，请不要勉强。不好意思。
No, no, no, of course. I think it's a super interesting question, which is, you know, do you, as a company, do you just want to deliver a platform or do you want to deliver the end solution? And Acasa's model is that we're a managed service, at least so far for most of our customers. How we run the model is that we not only build the platform, but we also understand the customer needs, build them a custom integration, and also handle maintenance and monitoring and healing or retraining the bot when something in the system changes so that the end goal is that we're a managed service and we can sort of deliver an end-to-end solution that the customer doesn't have to think a lot about.
不，不，不，当然。我认为这是一个超级有趣的问题，那就是，作为一个公司，你只是想交付一个平台，还是想交付最终的解决方案？Akasa的模式是我们是一个托管服务提供商，至少对我们大多数客户来说到目前为止是这样的。我们运营模式的方式是，我们不仅构建平台，我们还了解客户需求，为他们构建自定义集成，并在系统发生变化时处理维护、监控、修复或重新训练机器人，因此最终目标是我们是一个托管服务，我们可以提供端到端的解决方案，客户无需为此多虑。
There are other companies that are more focused on, you know, we're going to give you the tools and then you can use these tools to build whatever you want. And there's obviously trade-offs there for the customer. You know, in that case for the customer, they would have to hire engineers internally and go build something and then hire a maintenance team to, you know, write some alerts and monitor them and be proficient enough to fix them if something goes wrong. So I think this is almost like what we talked about earlier. Software-first companies or non-software-first companies, there's a big difference. And then even within software-first companies, there's this difference
还有其他公司更专注于，我们要给你这些工具，然后你可以用这些工具来构建任何你想要的东西。这显然对客户来说有相应的权衡。在这种情况下，客户必须在内部聘请工程师去构建一些东西，然后聘请维护团队来编写一些警报并进行监控，并且要精通在出错时修复它们。所以我觉得这几乎就像我们之前讨论的。软件优先公司和非软件优先公司之间有很大的区别。甚至在软件优先公司内部，也有这种区别
of do you handle the integrations for your customers? Or do you just build the platform and release it? And so far, we've thought about it as a managed service, which has shown to be pretty valuable for our customers. Nice. Yeah, I think that's like another one of those recurring or even like, with like you were describing the sort of like platform team versus the integration team doing these things like even split within a company or whether like the team should be forced to consume its own dog food i guess like at some point it grows but like should the team itself be responsible also also for writing them so i guess like a couple more
即你是为客户处理集成，还是只构建平台并发布它？到目前为止，我们一直将其视为一种托管服务，这已被证明对我们的客户非常有价值。太好了。是的，我觉得这就像是那些反复出现的问题之一，甚至就像你所描述的平台团队与集成团队做这些事情一样，公司内部甚至存在分歧，或者团队是否应该被迫“吃自己的狗粮”，我猜在某种程度上它会成长，但是团队本身是否也应该负责编写它们，所以我想还有几个
questions about about some of the specifics one is a little goofy one's a little more serious i'll start with the serious one first and i'll ask the goofy one uh so there's a more serious question is like not from a like obviously like health care laws in the u.s are complex and they are what they are um and there's a lot of you know focus on that but from a technical level do you guys with all of this stuff we're talking about software but the environment and the data is i guess particularly unique here and that like it's medical information there there are regulations, I think, in the US, we have laws like HIPAA laws for the privacy of people's medical information. Does that cause a lot of complication for you guys? Like where the processing needs to be run, how the data is stored?
关于具体细节的问题，一个是有点滑稽，另一个比较严肃，我先从严肃的开始，然后再问滑稽的。所以更严肃的问题是，不是从……显然美国的医疗保健法律很复杂，它们就是那样的，并且有很多对此的关注，但从技术层面来看，我们讨论的虽然都是软件，但这里的环境和数据我想特别独特，因为它是医疗信息，美国有很多法规，我想我们有像HIPAA法案这样的法律来保护人们医疗信息的隐私。这会给你们带来很多麻烦吗？比如处理需要在哪里运行，数据如何存储？
Like, does it need to be on premise at the hospital? Like at a technical level? What kind of issues does that cause? Yeah, it's a great question. And yeah, we take security very, very seriously. So I would say one thing that was unique about Acasa compared to most startups I've seen is that really from day one, we had a very legit infrastructure and security team, because that's super, super important when you're working with patient data. And yeah, it does cause, you know, some, I would say complications. But I think because we went in eyes wide open, and from day zero, we were planning on building for healthcare, we were able to architect our platform around it. One thing that you'll often see that can be troublesome is when a otherwise normal software company tries to
比如它需要放在医院的本地服务器上吗？在技术层面？这会引起什么样的问题？是的，这是一个很好的问题。是的，我们非常非常重视安全。所以我想说，与我见过的绝大多数初创公司相比，Akasa独特的一点在于，从第一天起，我们就拥有一个非常正规的基础设施和安全团队，因为在处理患者数据时，这超级超级重要。是的，这确实会带来，我想说的一些麻烦。但我认为，因为我们一开始就睁大眼睛看清了这一点，从第零天起我们就计划为医疗保健构建产品，所以我们能够围绕它来构建我们的平台架构。你经常会看到的一件令人头疼的事情是，当一个原本正常的软件公司试图
enter the healthcare space. And, you know, they have a lot of interesting functionality that can be useful. But now they realize they have to store their data in different ways and they have to log who accesses every type of data and, you know, they can't, you know, data has to be encrypted. And then it just causes a whole bunch of problems for people who sort of tack on healthcare as an afterthought. So I'd say we basically built for healthcare from the beginning, which has made it be pretty smooth because we knew exactly what we were getting into and could plan for it before we got too big or before there was, you know, any technical debt or of requirements that I won't be able to go over all right now. But, you know, some of the general ideas are that, you know, all patient data needs to be encrypted, both, you know, at rest, for example, when it's, you know, sitting in an S3 bucket, and also in transit, you know, when it's like, you know, being shuttled between services or, you know, being returned as a response from an API endpoint.
进入医疗保健领域。并且，他们有很多有趣的、可能有用的功能。但现在他们意识到必须以不同的方式存储数据，他们必须记录谁访问了每种类型的数据，并且数据必须加密。这就给那些把医疗保健当作事后想法硬塞进来的人带来了一堆问题。所以我想说，我们从一开始就是为医疗保健构建的，这使得过程相当顺利，因为我们确切地知道我们在涉足什么，并且在我们变得太大之前，或者在我们有任何技术债或我现在无法一一列举的需求之前就可以进行规划。但是，一些总体思路是，所有患者数据都需要加密，无论是在静态时（例如，当它存储在S3桶中时），还是在传输中（例如，在服务之间传输或作为API端点的响应返回时）。
And additionally, you know, there needs to be access logging on any patient data. And so, and you need to make sure that people only access data on what's called the need to know basis. So basically ensuring that we're treating the patient data with the utmost respect and privacy, and that it's always encrypted so that, you know, even though we have several layers of defense, even if any of those were compromised, the data would be encrypted still. Awesome. Thank you. All right. So I have one more silly question before we transition into sort of like a little bit more about Acasa itself is that you were talking about the automations for going into these UIs and sort of like you're searching the same as a lot of other people you weren't thinking about. And so the one I was thinking of here, I guess it was a silly and you feel free not to answer.
此外，需要对任何患者数据进行访问日志记录。因此，你需要确保人们只在所谓的“按需知道”的基础上访问数据。所以基本上要确保我们以最大的尊重和隐私对待患者数据，并且它始终是加密的，这样一来，尽管我们有多层防御，即使其中任何一层被攻破，数据仍然是加密的。太棒了。谢谢。好的。在我过渡到更多关于Akasa本身的话题之前，我还有一个有点傻的问题，你之前谈到针对这些UI的自动化，以及你如何搜索，这和很多其他人一样，你当时没有多想。所以我想到的这个，我想这确实有点傻，你觉得不回答也没关系。
It's just like this feels like all those people writing the online like poker bots and like aim bots and she like I'm looking for pixels on screen and scraping the screen. It feels like the APIs I would use for Windows or whatever, or Linux to kind of get that information. If I write those search queries into Google, I feel like I'm going to end up in a specific use that has nothing to do with medical records. Yeah, it's super interesting. It's a very interesting question that you ask. And I think a lot of those, you know, like in my past in college and whatnot, I'd written scrapers and things like that. And how you see a lot of robotic process automation done is basically people, you know,
这感觉就像所有那些编写在线扑克机器人和自瞄机器人的人，就像我正在寻找屏幕上的像素并抓取屏幕。这感觉就像我会用来获取该信息的Windows或Linux的API。如果我把这些搜索查询输入谷歌，我觉得我最终会进入一个与医疗记录毫无关系的特定领域。是的，超级有趣。这是一个非常有趣的问题。我想在我的过去，在大学之类的时期，我写过抓取器之类东西。你看到很多机器人流程自动化（RPA）的做法基本上是人们
hardcoding pixel coordinates on the screen, you know, they treat the screen as an axis, as a grid, excuse me. And then they say, okay, my button is that this X, Y coordinate on the screen, and they hard code that into the code. Or sometimes they'll, you know, slightly more advanced users will will sort of take a screenshot and then crop out the specific, you know, logo or button that they're looking for. And then they'll use something like OpenCV to tell me, you know, find me this image on the screen, and then they'll use something like OpenCV to tell me, you know, find me this image on the screen, and then they'll get the pixel coordinates and interact with it. And Acosta's model is a little bit different, where it's more about actually training a
在屏幕上对像素坐标进行硬编码，他们把屏幕当作一个轴，当作一个网格，不好意思。然后他们说，好吧，我的按钮在屏幕上的这个X、Y坐标，然后他们把这个硬编码到代码中。或者有时他们会，稍微高级一点的用户会截个图，然后裁剪出他们正在寻找的特定徽标或按钮。然后他们会使用类似OpenCV的东西告诉我，在屏幕上找到这个图像，然后他们会使用类似OpenCV的东西告诉我，在屏幕上找到这个图像，然后他们会获取像素坐标并与之交互。而Akasa的模式有点不同，它更多的是关于实际训练一个
computer vision algorithm to understand what's on the screen and be able to effectively generate a DOM telling us which elements are on the screen. And then we also have more domain specific algorithms. So for example, if we end up on, you go to the doctor's office and they ask for your insurance card and they scan it into the system that gives them, you know, JPEPEG or a PNG, but no structured data that they can index and search. But we have algorithms, for example, part of our computer vision algorithm can read these scanned images of insurance cards and extract all the structured information as well. So yeah, it's an interesting question you ask, which is basically, you know, how this space started is a lot of what you mentioned, you know, how this space started is a lot of what you
计算机视觉算法来理解屏幕上的内容，并能够有效地生成一个DOM来告诉我们屏幕上有哪些元素。然后我们还有更多特定领域的算法。例如，如果你最终去到医生办公室，他们要求你提供保险卡并将其扫描到系统中，这会给你一个JPEG或PNG，但没有可供他们索引和搜索的结构化数据。但我们有算法，例如，我们计算机视觉算法的一部分可以读取这些扫描的保险卡图像并提取所有结构化信息。所以是的，你问了一个有趣的问题，也就是这个领域是如何起步的，正如你提到的有很多，这个领域是如何起步的，正如你
mentioned, you know, people building bots for poker or something like that. But over time, we've kind of evolved. And I think especially with modern machine learning approaches, that helps us take a different approach to it. Awesome. You turned a silly question into a serious answer. That's applause worthy. Awesome. So tell us a bit about, I mean, we kind of heard a bit of the story of Akasa and what you guys are doing and how you're doing it. Are you guys like, for, are you mostly in office? Are you doing a little bit of remote work? Are you guys hiring? Like what's kind of the state of Akasa these days? Yeah, absolutely. Acasa is doing really well and growing very fast. So I think we're up to about 250 full-time employees now, which I joined the company
提到的，人们为扑克之类的事情编写机器人。但随着时间的推移，我们已经演变了。而且我认为特别是通过现代机器学习方法，这帮助我们采取了不同的方法来对待它。太棒了。你把一个愚蠢的问题变成了一个严肃的回答。这值得鼓掌。太棒了。那么给我们讲讲，我的意思是，我们已经听了一点Akasa的故事，以及你们在做什么和你们是怎么做的。你们是主要在办公室工作吗？你们是在做远程办公吗？你们在招聘吗？这几天Akasa的状态怎么样？是的，绝对的。Akasa发展得非常好，而且增长非常快。所以我想我们现在大约有250名全职员工了，我是加入公司的
almost three years ago. So October 2019, I think we were about five or 10 people back then. So it's been tremendous growth. Company is fully remote friendly. So, you know, I'd say by virtue of where you find software engineers, a lot of software engineers still happen to live in the Bay Area. But, you know, on my team, we have people all over the country and we're a remote company at this point.
快三年了。所以大约是2019年10月，我想那时我们大约有五到十人。所以这是巨大的增长。公司完全支持远程办公。所以，你可以说，由于软件工程师分布的地方，很多软件工程师碰巧仍然住在湾区。但是，在我的团队中，我们有来自全国各地的人，在这一点上我们是一家远程公司。
And absolutely, we're hiring for all sorts of engineering and product roles. So specifically, right now, we're hiring full stack engineers, as well as data engineers and front end engineers. So hiring across the board, basically. Nice. Yeah. And we'll have the link in the show notes to the career page. I mean, go check it out. And do you guys do internships for summer interns? We do. We've
当然，我们在招聘各种工程和产品职位。具体来说，目前我们正在招聘全栈工程师，以及数据工程师和前端工程师。基本上全面都在招聘。太好了。是的。我们将在节目说明中提供招聘页面的链接。我的意思是，去看看吧。你们为暑期实习生提供实习机会吗？我们提供。我们已经
done some machine learning internships, and we've also done a couple of software engineering internships. Nice. I think an internship at a startup might be particularly interesting rather than a startup at a big company. I feel like there's like a big compare and contrast there. But I feel like that could be really interesting. Yeah, I will say when I was in college, I interned at two startups, and I found it to be a really interesting experience. Because first of all, the stuff you build actually gets used in production, just because, you know, a lot of startups are started for resources. And so if they have someone, they'll put you on something that's useful and that they really need to get done,
做过一些机器学习实习，我们也做过几个软件工程实习。太好了。我认为在初创公司的实习可能比在大公司实习更有趣。我觉得这里面有很大的对比。但我觉得这真的很有趣。是的，我会说当我上大学时，我在两家初创公司实习过，我发现这是一次非常有趣的体验。首先，你构建的东西实际上会被用于生产环境，只是因为很多初创公司资源有限。所以如果他们有人的话，他们会让你去做有用且他们真正需要完成的事情，
which I thought was pretty cool. And also you get to see the inner workings of the company a little bit more when it's smaller. You get to see how things work and how projects get planned. Whereas probably at a bigger company, you'll learn a ton as well and work on great technology. But a lot of that, you know, vision or design is already
我觉得这挺酷的。而且当公司规模较小时，你能更多地了解公司的内部运作。你能看到事情是如何运作的以及项目是如何规划的。而在一个更大的公司里，你可能也会学到很多东西并使用伟大的技术。但是很多那样的愿景或设计，在你来到之前
done for you before you before you come in. Yeah, that was well said. All right. Well, awesome. Thank you so much for joining the show today, Sanjay. I think there's a great like, we interweaved the kind of narratives together, but I feel it was a great exploration of of kind of this space and the domain and the sort of this balance between general purpose solutions and like specific things. I really enjoyed our conversation today. Thank you so much for coming on the show. Thank you so much for having me. All right. And to everyone listening, thank you again for hanging with us for another episode. We're getting close to the end of the year and it's been another awesome time. I think this is
就已经为你做好了。是的，说得太好了。好的。非常感谢你今天来到节目中，桑杰（Sanjay）。我觉得这是一个很好的，我们将这些叙事交织在一起，但我认为这是对这个领域、这个领域的技术以及通用解决方案与特定事物之间这种平衡的一次很好的探索。我非常喜欢我们今天的对话。非常感谢你来到节目。非常感谢邀请我。好的。对于所有听众，再次感谢你们陪伴我们又度过了一期节目。我们快接近年底了，这是又一段美好的时光。我想这是
episode 149. So I don't know, 150 is next. That sounds like a nice ending in zero numbers. So maybe we'll have to think of special music to play in the beginning or something. I'll get Jason to record us something. All right. We'll see y'all next time see y'all later music by eric barnmeller programming throwdown is distributed under a creative commons attribution share alike 2.0 license. You're free to share, copy, distribute, transmit the work, to remix, adapt the work, but you must provide attribution to Patrick and I and share alike in kind. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
第149集。所以我想，第150集就在后面。这听起来像是一个以零结尾的好数字。所以也许我们得想想在开头播放什么特殊的音乐或者别的什么。我会让杰森给我们录点东西。好的。我们下次再见，回头发。埃里克·巴恩梅勒（Eric Barnmeller）的音乐。编程抛锚（Programming Throwdown）在知识共享署名-相同方式共享2.0协议下分发。你可以自由分享、复制、分发、传输该作品，以及进行混音和改编，但你必须向帕特里克和我提供署名，并以相同方式分享。这期节目还没有评论。点击文字记录中的任何句子即可发表评论。